two hello hello
we're back baby
that's right another week of H3 podcast
it's Monday July 31st a beautiful summer
day
the hottest summer in the history of
human recording nothing to worry about
folks
nothing to see here y'all okay I
speaking of climate change
um so you guys have probably heard about
this like
people talk about this when we were kids
you'd road trip and there'd be a ton of
bugs on your windshield
now when you road trip there's almost no
bugs on the window
I've noticed that phenomenon you haven't
I for sure noticed that yeah like I we
used to drive and it would be
caked with dead insects and now there's
like nothing
I get pretty cake still
I don't not to be contrarian but you can
be contrarian but I I've seen people
talk about this and I've 100 noticed it
myself interesting nobody else here I
saw the study you were talking about the
windshield phenomenon
the windshield it's a phenomenon it is
it's on Wikipedia even and so
my initial reaction was like oh it's
probably just because cars today are
more aerodynamic and so the bugs aren't
splatting they're blowing over the top
okay but I read
and I don't know what to believe but
this possibility is really effed up
since the 2000s
when we were kids there's been a 60
percent decrease in flying bugs 60
percent
I'm good with that all flying bugs that
sounds like great news that is actually
I mean that means that basically we're
all about to die I mean I'm not even
kidding the bugs disappear that's like
90 of all
food in the ecosystem I I don't like
when bugs fly
this sounds like good news to me land
bound bugs they're gross
blind bugs are gross you think that
Bell's tolling for the bug stand it's
not
yeah
it's telling for the humans
you want to go down with the bugs
or you want to fly
with the bugs but what I what I would
like to know is which one is true
because to me
the idea that we're not splatting bugs
just because they're not they don't live
anymore is pretty disturbing
in just 20 years the bugs are all gone
can anybody fact check that
I feel like it's Gotta I see there is a
brief Wikipedia article called the
windshield phenomenon about the
observation the fewer dead insects
accumulate on windshields and front
bumpers in front of cars since the early
2000s
uh there was a 20-year study in Denmark
uh from 1997 to 2017
when they adjusted for all the variables
they found an 80 decline in insects 80
that's what it says
and is can we cite can we check that
like I almost don't believe it can we
check the source on that
it's just some research paper I'm seeing
NPR said that a 60 decrease since 2004
so so we're saying it's the decrease in
bugs I mean this is very disturbing
why why is this not like at the
Forefront of our minds
60 to 80 percent of bugs are just
[__] dead
gone
how many animals eat bugs and part of
and part of the you know ecosystem birds
reptiles she's awesome lizards
everything eats bugs
what the hell is gonna happen what are
we gonna do without bugs
bugs that are flying everywhere
they're doing impossible things
have you ever sat on a giant piece of
[__] and feasted on it no
the Flies do that what other people
won't do
[Music]
they're laying eggs in giant piles of
[__]
they're landing on [__] and then flying
into your bowl of kung pao chicken yep
does the [__] carry from their legs onto
the Kung Pow chicken it's impossible to
know
what about the frogs what do they
[Music]
Moss
they turned the freaking frogs gay
and moth is about that is genuinely
disturbing though nobody nobody wants
bugs huh what are are moths not bugs
moths are bugs they are yeah right why
you say Moss or Moss yeah because you
suggested moths as in oh ma yeah but he
can eat vegetables
hell no hell no
nobody can nobody's disturbed by that
I'm disturbed by a lot of things you
know what I mean I only got so much
Disturbed 80 of bugs are dead yeah lots
of things it's also the hottest year on
record is also we're also we're killing
literally my body is full of plastic
bleach I already deal with a good amount
of existential dreads yeah I'm just kind
of like
yeah
these bugs are gross when I was a kid
the bugs were everywhere you know what
global warming is so so scary horrible
all the way around if maybe there are a
few less corpses of uh insects on my
windshield I'm okay with that no bugs
pollinate here she comes
[Applause]
ela's here for our big announcement
we were talking before oh oh hi hi hi
well
beautiful
did you know that
we were just talking I want to get your
take on this before the big announcement
do you have a minute yeah okay good
do you remember when you were a kid and
you would do long drives your windshield
would be caked in bugs there'd be tons
of dead bugs from the bumper on the
windshield everything now there's no
bugs
right this is a known phenomenon the
windshield phenomenon interesting
they've done tests and apparently the
reason is
is because
from 2000 to today 60 to 80 percent of
all flying insects are dead whoa
is that disturbing that's crazy nobody
cares about the [__] bugs dude
science is gay yeah not really they're
kind of annoying but that is crazy it's
gonna destroy it's gonna ruin everything
there's already things like existential
things I worry about so all right so
which one's better than the bug one what
are you tripping about Zach I don't know
dude Birds a lot Birds is one leave them
alone Coral bleaching well the birds are
gonna stop the birds are gonna suffer
from the bugs and what's what are those
sea urchin anonymity what are they
[__] called um why are you worried
about sea urchins I don't know they're
cooler than [__] bugs they are
coolers no he's right um are they dying
or something not maybe I don't know
you're having existential threat about
sea urchins yeah yeah dude
who's counting the bugs are they
counting them one by one are they making
them feel sense of surveys how do they
quantify that they drive through the
country and count how many are [__]
dead on their Windows well maybe they're
the problem look at them they're going
out of their way to kill these bugs
let's talk about all these damn signs no
wonder there's lessons there's no
problems is it government-funded
institution are they indecking you know
Danish people Wayne Denmark
you've been warning us dude it's a big
coke involved guys pull it together
[__] Denmark the Danes eat bugs yeah
they do
Jesus Christ man is it a research by
Coca-Cola
is it paid for by the beverage
Association
all right listen I don't want to waste
your time all right you look beautiful
thank you I like your outfit what's
going on thank you what is that on your
legs what is that they're like little
tights
it's like a stress safe kind of
undergarments between your legs
but they are cool I like them you're
also virtually translucent
okay
um so I came here because I finally got
the results
oh you did
you'll never get and guess what it is
what is it
I'm pregnant
[Applause]
I am 100 knew you were pregnant I mean
the weekend was so obvious yeah she's
like hungry she's like easy can you make
me tacos
she's tired she's hungry yep
you had a headache or something yeah
that's a big one if you have a headache
ladies pregnant only explanation
but um there it is and most of all I
knew you were good it was gonna work is
because it's a boy right right
it's so crazy this decline boys we're
just so destined to have boys but you
know what I really think that there's a
good chance that I mean you never know
what they might identify as once they
grow right but out of three
one might be
so you're hoping that one will be open
to changing his um sexual identity for
you
very Progressive okay absolutely yeah
it's true I still have a girl you can
still have a girl
we'll have to wait and see I guess
they're beautiful
that's uh optimistic I like that
we'll have to pull them when they're
like
18.
hey so listen mom's been wondering any
girl in you who's taking one for the
team one of you boys needs a switch for
Mom
yeah well Mazel Tov guys yeah
congratulations three boys man the third
time is so different like the first time
was like we're like on the edge of our
seats everything is insane it's so crazy
yeah the second time was it's like hmm
we're doing it again I can't remember
stuff yeah it was pretty exciting yeah I
mean not that it's not exciting now but
now it's like we weren't even thinking
about it
and I'm almost not even I'm only I'm not
even gonna know what's happening until
that baby's born yeah think about it
dude there's gonna be zero prep in this
house this time we don't need to yeah
it's like at least for like a Whole
Decade now it's like we already have
everything
it's just whenever the baby's gonna be
ready to pop out same gender we just
Mainline them through all the clothes
leftover diapers potty training bikes
toy it's like everything's right here
for you
we don't have a name yet at that point
no we don't we had a name
Percy Ducey and well I mean the girl
name Oh Olive we already said it right
yeah we already said it okay
Olive is officially retired yeah Olive
is retired you name Oliver that's what
everybody says and you know what
Theodore likes it theater is obsessed
with it he's like Oliver I am not
I'll tell you but not
Oliver tree not name your son Matt just
because I can and I am
because frankly I like the name Oliver
too and if I didn't know him I'd
probably name we'd probably think about
it that's what I'm saying I can't do it
it's not worth it I can't give that to
him
he'll never shut the [__] up for as long
but it's kind of a perfect name and Tito
loves it
he's moved on he's moved on he's just
moved on or like it can't feel good
Ethan Jr people like junior or maybe
after their favorite uncle Zach Lewis
you know Zach Lewis live in the world
yeah throw that in their middle name I'd
be honored you know
troubadour
um
yeah some of the other ones we're
thinking about was
people like Oliver but I'm telling you
guys it's not worth it
it will be so not worth it Monopoly on
that name you don't own that he'll come
out damaged
other ones we're thinking about is Levi
which I'm not sure
oh you like that because of the attack
on titans yeah I think mine goes too as
well that's a solid name that's a pretty
solid name I'm like
and then the other one was um there's
also the singer 11 11 Helm so we always
kind of like 11 but then that went out
of the list recently too yeah it just
sounds like lemon bread
which we're against as Jews right yeah
I've been bread it's when bread Rises
you know oh my God so we have we have
Levi what was the other one
Zach Lewis uh Winston Winston Winston I
like Winston that's cute it's a solid
name you guys like what that's from uh
adorable like a baby named Winston the
book um Sirens Sirens yeah this guy had
the best name ever and I thought it was
um so good and
what was there another one wasn't there
that might be all of our names oh his
name was um
Winston Niles Rumford III
such a great name
uh yeah okay Winston is might be good
people seem to like that
what about
um
well let's do a poll I'm curious what
the people think this poll is not
binding for the record no okay
non-binding pool Levi
[Music]
um Winston I was I was Oliver was still
keeping it in the question I pitched to
ELA Shredder Junior
he was not kidding
Shredder he actually you know he
suggested it as a middle name and he was
not kidding
because what's wrong with that so Ethan
was like you know how when somebody
passes away
you give the middle name after like a
grandparent or something so he's like so
well if something happens to Shredder
would you consider doing there well I
was like I want to honor him
well that could be for the next dog
no I'm not no but I don't know that you
could do that for the kid Shredder I
just I don't know about that I don't
know how they would feel about that
it's a badass name I'll give him some
guitar lessons so it'll it'll fit you
know he shreds yeah all right what do we
have on the um uh Levi Winston Oliver
and Shredder Jr no thank you brother uh
Alfredo no Alfredo Alfred somebody I
supposed to say that Dante I like that
kind of fire that's not like Italian
name though
it feels a little foreign to me
and which we don't like right just that
I don't know if I would if I would
connect with it right right right it's
not of Your World
I thought you were uh I thought you were
part Italian you know two percent yeah
he's 15 Italian 15. that's big that's
you can you get Italian aims at that
yeah at that point you're in you're in
the club and you come to me on the
day of my son's breath
in too fast
and you say to me
Walter that just makes me think of Over
The Line Breaking Bad
Walter all right let's throw it up what
we've got so far Arthur no it just makes
me think of Stephen Crowders
voicing for the show author Arthur he
did that yes his big break his first job
in acting he was a voice for one of the
cartoons on Arthur what but he was like
a kid right
teenager I think or yeah I know man
something happened between Arthur and
now that really [__] him up I have
some input from your mother Donna oh
great she said they should name the baby
after Grandma Eileen
okay
go on
just you have any that's not really
Eileen Shredder Clinic suggestion do you
want me to do you want us to name our
son Grandma Eileen what do you want
first name Grandma middle name is there
a is there a masculine form of Eileen
Donatello
you know what's her name that I always
loved um Alfonso or Alphonse Alfonso but
then he'll just be Al
which isn't the worst you can call him
out
you could call me out yeah what about uh
like like Xerxes
that's a strong name emperor of the uh
Persian Empire sure yeah uh Xerxes
Donna said Ezra
I like that Ezra Miller is that is that
oh Eileen
I don't I don't think so she bailed on
her own idea
I don't like Ezra it's just not like
nothing personal kid
isn't there
yeah there's a famous journalist named
Ezra Klein so it's taken anyways that's
true he's the This American Life guy
right right it's just all I can think of
is like some old Israeli men
not the vibe
well throw a Luigi
you said noted you said to know it to
Italian names and everything you've
suggested since then has been an Italian
zoning name I like the Italian names he
looks the one the xenophobe
I just didn't like Dante sorry Elliot
nah
[Music]
foreign oh you have a dark line that's
right we used to sit out here on the
board I didn't mean to get you started
like this somebody said Howie we know
about Elliot nah no I'm seeing a lot of
Freddy's Freddy we already have a Freddy
Alfredo true Elton uh Elton was
suggested by your mom we did think about
the job
Alfonso Antonio
uh your dad has a suggestion he said
Elon Elon oh my God that's the most
cursed name I could give a child right
now my mom would be so happy though
because it would be after her name
because her name is Ilana it's basically
the sand you know elon's not a bad name
but the Vibes right now are not right
yeah it's like terrible it's like naming
my son like Adolf yeah terrible it's not
a bad name really on face yeah
apparently it used to be an extremely
popular name I mean dude how many people
have just like ended a whole [__]
name he retired his jerseys that is a
great point I mean this is an
interesting suggestion does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey weinstein.com
fine interesting you know people
advertising people could um check and
see if anybody else has named that by
going to Google and searching that yeah
that would be yeah it would be able to
do a little research on that that's a
really good idea Googled Ryan Cavanaugh
and just look
Rupert Rupert rupee Matteo Atticus
that's nice how do you like that to Kill
a Mockingbird Atticus a Genghis
interesting what happened to Genghis
bring it back then now Gary just said uh
Evan Evan they're really on this e name
Eileen Ezra Elton Elon and Evan all
right I do like it because it starts
with aleph in Hebrew and I do generally
I like names that starts with olive this
guy
Pedro hey that's not even Italian
Phoenix
what about just like what if we got real
weird with it and you just give them
like river that there's River Phoenix
river is not that weird you go River but
I never met a river in my life it's just
a thing you go reach your River people
like it I don't think we're one of those
couples though clouds that go for the
weird names table yeah it's a little too
La what was George
soda I like soda I genuinely like soda
that's for a girl like the letter e you
said yeah
um okay I pulled up some e names Elias
Urkel Elias I think that's a nice name
Elias
Elijah
Enzo Enzo
Alden ring Klein
that's awesome yeah that's sick I'm
reading that there's a legal baby oh
that is kind of a cool name I don't like
Elton no Eldon ring oh Eldon without
waiting Eldon is that a real name I
don't know but it is nice yeah is that a
name Eldon Eldon I don't think so it is
now
but he's gonna know he's named after a
video game now Eldon is a boy's name of
Old English origin that means Ella's
Hill Gamers might recognize the name
from Elden rise the [__] up dude
I don't hate it also I like L as a
nickname oh yeah like 11. I like that
Elden
is there anything else that has an L in
it that we could maybe
play with like other than I mean I like
Elden though Elijah Elliot Eli
is better than all those names peace and
love to those people who have that name
I'm saying there's illegal baby names I
know that was a thing Elio illegal you
can't name your your baby like [__]
or something you can't name them king
queen Jesus Christ Santa Claus okay you
can't name them Jesus Christ
that's I can't name them Queen you can't
name them at oh Jesus this is a federal
law you're sure uh let me double check I
can't name my child
what about Jesus like that's a name
right yeah lots of people have the name
Jesus that's just Jesus in Spanish you
just can't have it right
okay that's true that's true well
somebody said Edward do you like that
that's my middle name I know that but do
you like it for a first name Edward Team
Edward Eddie Ed
I Don't Love Ed and Eddie but I think
Edward isn't I like Elden
which is [__] weird that's crazy
son it's time you played this game your
namesake
held in ring my son
sit around child it's time to learn
about your origin your mom suggests
Elvis Elvis
most overrated a meal magician ever
e-m-i-l-e I'm just going down the list
El Gordo or
Gordo what's the name of that oh El
Chapo what
a meal a meal yeah I'm ready to have a
meal not name my kids all right for sure
for sure for sure
[Music]
I'm hungry you just dunked on that baby
so hard
Eldon okay let's do a poll because I
actually like Eldon that's kind of hard
yelled okay so add Alden to those other
options Levi Winston Oliver and Eldon
here we go ask do you like Edward the
community I mean I don't my problem is
that I don't love the short Ed and eggy
Ed Ed and Eddie there's a cartoon that
Ed Eddie and Eddie Levi
Winston Oliver or Eldon which one are
you thinking
don't say it just point to it
[Music]
understand
what would be a knit a short name for
Winston
Winnie that's a little bit of a problem
for me that's adorable it's cute Winnie
I think it needs to have some kind of e
though Winnie I feel like in Hebrew that
that's going to become a Vinnie which I
don't like
they don't do W's in Hebrew
[Music]
Winnie the Pooh how do they call Winnie
the Pooh yeah
yeah weenie but it sounds weird
Oliver actually they don't he's just
called poo the bear food
let's say my poo then
I'm voting for that if you believe it
there are literary characters wow that's
crazy dude that's the one I voted for
Eldon
isn't that so weird Elden
Elden ring expansion pack win
is that it coming out I've been waiting
that's a great question so [__] long
they're [__] up my kid's gonna go to
my Elder's gonna go to college before
the album is so true I like Alden
mom and dad what do you guys think about
Elden
here's some rules to follow each state
has its own set of rules for naming
some states have more lenient
regulations While others have more
strict
common restrictions in various states
include special characters oh come on
how am I going to name my chat and my
password if I can't use special
characters
obscenities and offensive terms names
that are considered obscene offensive or
derogatory are typically not allowed
okay
lame boring numero numerals some states
do not permit the use of numbers well
that makes sense I mean wait so did
elon's son's name is that following the
guidelines I think Elon had to change it
if I'm not mistaken oh it didn't or
let's see
or no I don't or he initially wanted to
name him something else but had a chance
I think there wasn't a special character
it was just like a different it has a
dash in it but maybe dashes are okay
because I guess yeah names have hyphens
yeah you're right names have hyphens
recently Grimes and musk had to change
their sons
Betty Lou oh they do have the uh
whatever that
figure is the the A and E compound I
forgot yeah I think it's our region yeah
recently Grimes and musk had to change
their son's name to comply with
California law I know a lot of names
supposed to be written on birth
certificates using the 26 alphabetic
alphabetical letters of the English
language right oh so that they the
umlauts and the AE one has numbers in
there too so what do you think no
numbers Henry I just saw it in there
Henry mm-hmm
I don't hate Henry I don't hate it
Henry
[Laughter]
Henry III was one of the great Kings of
Lord of The Manor
we have a close friend named Isaac so
that one doesn't work
okay so people are liking Oliver now
Oliver overtook okay let's let's I still
like Oliver I do let's let's tone it
down let's tone it down let's do another
pull don't play that okay
I mean if we go for Oliver we might have
to burn all over three sound bites
banned from the show we might have to
from the soundboard cut any ties with
him we're cutting ties
it's gonna be so Non-Stop and so absurd
the kid's gonna be bullied before he's
even born
is that what you want
Woody
so what am I am I doing okay so just
with Queen Oliver Eldon Oliver
Eldon and do we like Henry do we want to
add Henry to the I like him right now
Henry Archduke Archduke Ferdinand
all these are very British coded Winston
as well you guys have like a whole
British theme Happening Here Oliver I
like old retirees like yeah sounding
names that nobody's used in 100 years
Emperor at some point no I was
suggesting Egbert oh Egbert Humperdinck
Eggbert
I like egg bar is that a name yeah
Arthur what about Gaylord
wait what do you mean that's her actual
name that's a popular name I don't
Gaylord [__] Egbert or you don't like
Gaylord why
yay
Eggbert is kind of fire Egbert it sounds
like eggplant you could call him eggy
that's dope
I still like horrible I still want to
call ICE I still like Duckworth
we cannot agree on that one Duckworth
yeah dude you call him ducky isn't that
Kendrick Mars yes yes
that's his that's his surname that's
where he got it Duckworth
ducky is the coolest [__]
nickname Ducky's cute yeah but Ducky's
cute like when they're a little kid I
don't know about it I like what adults
use like the like Teddy Roosevelt like
that's badass his name he still goes by
Teddy even though he's like a Rough
Rider he like you know does genocide on
Native Americans but he's still called
Teddy damn what a contrast
did he do genocide on Native Americans
Teddy or was it yeah they all did yeah
he did that he did that [__]
if you go to the museum of natural
history in uh New York City there's a
giant statue of Teddy Roosevelt and like
two Native Americans like
like it's so [__] up hold on let me
pull this up I think they removed it
recently because people were getting
upset
do you want me to put up this poll so
what are the options Oliver Eldon Henry
yes yes yes okay go ahead let's get it
okay which do you like question mark I
always like the name Henry but Abe
doesn't
make fun of me
and it just makes me think of Henry Hill
look at this [__] who's that from uh
Good Fellas
this is the what's agreed to you oh yeah
we walked by that a lot everyone's like
yeah my older I was always like this is
a little weird he's leading them out of
their ancestral homes
I read something that people were
getting oh yeah here it is controversial
Teddy Roosevelt statue removed from
outside New York City Museum
that must have happened she's 20 20.
so I wonder you walked by it when it was
still there we walked about it many
times right in front of
the Natural History Museum right in our
neighborhood yeah so what did they
replace it with I wonder
you know
uh okay well there it is Oliver seems to
be taking a slight edge here you guys
are [__] with us
okay
I don't know why you know I like the
name I like Oliver but I can't I feel
like this is a lifelong decision and I
don't think that this should affect it
yeah but then like some [__] okay but
they have to promise not to make fun of
him
who's they who's everybody watching
everybody who's aware it's gonna make
fun of your baby Oliver starts saying
[__] I'm gonna hit the button and hang
up on him all right he talks about our
son
button hang up yeah it's not happening
okay there's no grandfather there's no
Godfather [__] there's no
none of that well no the name of this
one at least
he'll know the name of that no he won't
forget this one right I still might not
know
I like Oliver that's the shame of it and
Teddy does too teddy gets very
passionate about this thing
like when we thought we might have a
girl a lavender that was the name he
wanted lavender lavender I was like Wow
and that that he made he brought that he
brought that off the sweetest thing and
I was like that is really a sweet
beautiful name yeah
it wasn't meant to be
we're only destined to have boys it's
absolutely it's absolutely
because if you think about it like
some families they'll have three four
five boys
but we did I never thought I would be
one of those persons though some
families have four or five
daughters right
which is pretty wild too I'm sure both
of our parents had both so I just felt
like that was just obvious we were gonna
have like right mix it up yeah but
um but here's the thing
we did IVF and you had like nine eggs I
mean like besides this right now there's
still seven more boys
all in good condition we're all lined up
ready to go it's crazy I was gonna say
it's like we had nine kids basically and
they're all boys yeah so damn if anybody
wants a climb boy and the one girl she
just didn't make it
God Rest their soul
I mean she never
she's just an egg right
yep just an egg yeah it never got
fertilized I think that's what the
problem was
my semen just [__] recoils at the
thought of a female egg what's beta they
go they go into like nah
all right chill so Oliver okay all right
I guess we have we have time though
we've still got time elden's kind of
fire though I do like Eldon
Abner
yeah
Hubert
Stanley Stanley Cup Klein
Maxwell nope
Omar
I'm just reading them off
Duckworth can you do it include duck
like genuinely I think it's such a good
name but you guys really think it's
[__] up huh
Duckworth
is that I don't know what are you guys
in the office thing
about Duckworth yeah goofy I'm sorry
very goofy yeah I don't like it that
kid's getting picked on wait Did anyone
say that nobody likes it yeah that kid
is definitely does someone say they like
it
I don't like it hard they
they
well what about ducky
I don't like it just ducky ducky Is So
Cute
Ducky is cute but like what's the full
name it feels like a new type nickname
his name's ducky
yeah it's gonna be cool till he's like
damn sounds like a written toddler you
know what I mean like a toddler just
look at Dan's face like just look at
that how about Dan
then it's a good Jewish name Daniel
Klein Daniel yeah
he's a prophet or something Mr Beast
cool guy General cool that's awesome
just name him Mr Beast you should name
him Mr middle name my son after Mr Beast
Mr Beast dude
number five Mr beasts
baby
I have a meeting at two so I I'm
throwing my newborn baby into a giant
ditch on top of a birded train his name
is Mr B I tied up an FBI
I gotta go oh I must pass out from
coffee
I have a lot of time to think about this
I said Rocky Rocky Rocky you guys are
thinking of like Italian maybe I'm out
on Rocky how about Prometheus Prometheus
how about Tiamat promo
hey promo or Elvis like Dumbledore
Albus oh Elvis kind of
mm-hmm it's too much like oh you named
your kid from Harry Potter yeah
yeah you know I mean it's rough I'd
rather do Harry
if we're gonna go Harry Potter Harry
balls why don't you just name him hairy
balls
why do you name him toddler I think if
his name was Harry balls to be picked on
less than if his name was ducky oh my
god do you hear that that's [__]
let's call him LMAO
Everett Finnegan
Mordecai Buckley
Ember Amber's then I'll color my eyes
and your energy and your energy yeah and
my energy what about a Zeppelin
what okay
that's what I mean my first one
good I'm glad it's meaningless for you
it works for you I like it works for
Zaki what about Howard how there you go
is I kind of think it's a good name but
I wouldn't do it because it's too much
like oh you like Howard Stern well and
Howard always is like my name sucks I
have the worst name I disagree I think
it's a cool name no offense to the
Howards
no it's not a bad name it's just so it's
just very like Howard yeah you can be
Howie Rexford Rexford Lawrence
Rex Hazel Lawrence Hazel Oppenheimer
Smith
Don Jacob Oppenheimer Smith
you see these chat GPT uh
Elden ring-like names that was sick hold
on some good ones in here Elmo uh as a
language so here uh Elmo Chachi BT gave
dude almost kind of fire isn't that
Saint Elmo wait we actually said that as
a joke but now I like him he was like
what but he lives on Sesame yeah what
and what is ours brother gonna live on
Sesame Street
yeah
damn he's got jokes boys got jokes okay
so um okay I do have an appointment hold
on hold on hold on so jachibidi gave us
suggestions other than duck okay
Duckworth duckling ducky Duckett ducky
duckson duck cart duckford duckling
ducklinson yeah
yeah dude you can't these are all
terrible you can't name your kid
anything that rhymes with [__] oh it's
just gonna be endless teeth oh I even
think about that here's some other Elden
ring-like names alrik Gwen
Artorias artorius lother Sigmund lothar
damn ethyl Emerick Arden
Ireland
hold door
oh just name him Hodor Hodor these are
just scandini yeah I was gonna say these
all just sound like uh you know
would you consider Ethan or no
Ethan like Ethan Jr nah you don't want
to get I feel like giving your your name
your son junior is like I don't know
it's like wow you really love yourself
yeah it's like dude way to [__] you
know you got to give your your kid their
own identity I also know like not a lot
of Jewish people do that like it's not a
thing in Israel yeah
it's arrogant isn't it like I don't even
know how to say it
I think if you're a king I get it was
like yo we're royalty [__] it's one
name is all we [__] need
air is under a lot either but we take
our father's name as our middle name
which kind of stuff that's good I like
that I mean that that's like an honorary
you know yeah I think it's cool but for
the girls it sucks sometimes like Lena's
Lena Ahmed uh Ahmed which is a male name
yeah I like Ahmed that's a nice name by
the way
I always thought that was a nice name
Augustus glump Donna says tell Ethan
Everest Everest
she also suggested Eagle Eagle
she said eagle
any other animals you want oh I guess I
did say ducking Eagle Fang she's like if
duckies are lame then Eagles must be
cool
pterodactyl Cline
Tyrannosaurus that's the big ones yeah
quarrel code is Klein how about
alligator Klein yeah
what about Ken Elton all right we we
have time to think we hammerhead sharks
we can do this every episode congrats
I'm excited we're gonna do it another
[__] baby another boy
another Cline boy World Get Ready Get
Ready
no
[Applause]
if we order food do you want something
I'm feeling like celebratory Taco Bells
in order
to follow me
what
super lumba Klein
the potato taco thing or the fried
chicken taco the Chipotle she's pregnant
ela's back dude you gotta I love
pregnancy is back
you're ready to [__] eat
that is something you'll never hear not
pregnant you'll ever say yeah she's like
yo I need that I need two of those
[__] tacos
let love order for me all right
so okay we have some good options though
at the end of the day here we've got
Eldon Oliver
an eagle hell yeah I like Eagle I knew
an eagle once who did you he was a nice
guy okay that was Eagle if you're
watching I knew a hawk once
short for Hawking
I love chicken once
his name is chicken what about Griffith
then Dan let's just go with Griffith
oh God Goods guts yeah this name is
wait guts is crazy man Gustavo
it it all right all right we talked
about this enough let's move on yeah we
have a show to do here folks
so should we just change the title to
we're having another
boy do you think that's better yeah yeah
or we've got a big you're less pregnant
again Eli's pregnant again yeah
sad face kidding
never crazy Joy's face Joy's face happy
face there it is
[Applause]
there it is yeah tell Lina what you guys
want from
uh
there's nothing ordinary about it
where was that from remember that [__]
no there's nothing ordinary about it
it's like a commercial Bell that was a
Taco Bell jingle yeah bro
I think oh my God
1996. that's what it's from whoa what's
up dude it's weird how these Jingles
just stay with you yeah this is
look how old I am
God I was 11 when this came out so I was
like well my memory was working am I
gonna claimed
I do oh [__]
yo how is this a Taco Bell commercial
what am I watching right now oh my God
but it's cool all right let me hear the
sound
okay turn it off
okay
they're really trying to make this look
like real food yeah they gave up on that
they're like no no let's just get a
talking [__] dog in here
okay bring it back
[Music]
yeah I
I don't remember that one at all wow
it's been too young I would be what nine
eight years old
yeah it was uh yeah all right well let's
get some let's get some Taco Bell
let's go
oh yeah I want a Baja Blast most deaf oh
Baja Blast diet bro the Taco Bell
website isn't loading Taco Bell all
right so here's what we did over the
weekend actually we kind of
uh
uh we threw we threw out a uh
how do I say
we threw out a decoy we said we were
going to Saddle Ranch but we weren't
going to saddle rain it was a lie we
lied to you guys we went to Martin's
Restaurant Gwen and it was so good we
had such a fun experience Martin took
great care of us he really did and it
was such a great beautiful evening uh
I'm not in the photo because I missed
the memo and showed up at Saddle Ranch
alone
I missed you guys wow it was getting
left early cam bailed before dessert for
a good reason so it was uh it was great
it was fun he really hooked it up that
was it was amazing first first Michelin
star restaurant I'd ever been to so that
was that was cool yeah man it's a really
nice spot Gwen I mean it's super
expensive but if you're in if you want
to try a nice
what's interesting about it you know it
was expensive
as bad as I was it was thought it was
going to be it was a lot less than I
thought it would be yeah like a lot less
I mean uh Martin did hook it up with
like a nice employee discount 30 thank
you Martin you did Chris give us a fat
discount
but um it was a lot of money because
there was 12 of us or 13 of us or
however many there was but um but
considering that I agree
fairly reasonable for how for how nice
it was
I mean I'll say it because I actually I
thought it was fine it was like 1500
after a 400 tip yeah it was like 1100
yeah 1500 which that's a lot of money
but it was 12 13 people yeah how many
was it was it 12 or 13. I think was it
12 yeah 12 people I mean that's under a
hundred bucks ahead 12. for a Michelin
star restaurant that seems really good I
went there expecting to spend
300 per head right yeah that's what I
would have guessed so I was like [__]
yeah dude
300. somebody said okay but how was the
water you know oh that [__] was [__]
filmed that for a vlog right Lena
yes we did so we we arrived at the table
and there's just this massive spread of
all different kinds of waters boy
um so yeah the water was on point you
know it was
[Music]
wait you can get a frozen Baja Blast the
[__] yeah yes they didn't do that can
you get a diet the zero you know what
though it's gonna be yeah by the time it
gets here I wouldn't advise it yeah the
ordering the Baja Blast is no bueno you
got to do the free you got to be there
in person if you're gonna do the freeze
um I'm doing the freeze regardless but
yeah you're gonna regret that no I never
do I did it last time too and it was
still good when it got always great I
want it okay I want a Baja Blast zero no
sugar in that [__] extra extra freezy
what if it doesn't come with no sugar I
don't think then I don't want it yeah I
don't think they do the Freezy but oh
they don't not zero sugar it's racist
we'll still double check though
I went to Taco Bell and it ruined the
rest of my week they didn't hover the
they didn't have the Blended and then I
had a hard time
if they don't have it just a regular
Frozen one God I can't decide what to
get you guys are all having these
interesting orders I was diagnosed as
delusional so I came home and went to
bed
I need to start saying that
love her
I like your order love for crunchy Taco
Supremes yep that I love the tacos
Supreme it's like it's so simple
it hits so hard some Diablo sauce on
that [__] but why do you get the taco
supreme without tomatoes that's like the
whole thing I just want the sour cream
okay that's all so maybe it would be
cheaper to get just normal but sour
cream it's like 20 cents tomorrow or
something yeah
I don't know do they have those Chipotle
Ones Still I I can't open the website
Chipotle what Chipotle Taco something
chicken oh of course yeah I'm sure just
makes just tell them stuff they'll
figure it out can I get a Chipotle
Dorito wrap okay yeah it's all like
there's like five basic ingredients of
all of Taco Bell that exactly put some
different type of oil that's Mexican
food you're just that's true you're
ordering a shape you're ordering a form
factor can I get beans in a square yeah
I get one square one triangle yeah
exactly bean I want beans rice and uh
cheese and uh and some lettuce can I get
a cube of stuff if you say you want a
circle they'll give you Mexican pizza
can I get that heavy on the Crunchwrap
Supreme yeah Crunchwrap hexagon right
Supreme for real I love the crunch
Crunchwrap solid the Crunch Wrap solid
I'm looking at Dan because he's a Taco
Bell Aficionado two spicy potato soft
tacos yeah I'm going light today I'm not
that hungry we ate not that long before
the show started
um
all right so here's what I want
after much deliberation and spying on
everyone's order
Zach got the trench red Supreme and a
chalupa a Chupa Lupa yeah you don't want
a soup
make up for oh yeah it's not gonna
arrive yeah they [__] me the driver
will eat it just put a note you can eat
the Chupa Loompa that's for you
one tacos for you buddy
do that let's do that
Adam should we not invite him to go
through it no for that give him a tip
instead
well we yeah of course we test you know
what I mean yeah
cheers my dude
I can't decide I'm gonna sit I I don't
know I'm paralyzed with [__] choices
no just take your time all right one
taco supreme nope one bean cheese rice
burrito
with uh extra
mild sauce it tastes better don't judge
me I like the mild the hot doesn't taste
is good
you want extra sauce inside of it yes
please okay
[Music]
you like the chicken quesadilla maybe I
find it to be a little weird
he's fixing his wires but yeah he always
gets set
all right then let oh wait ELO wants
what did ELO want dude I'm so I'm so
sorry do you guys watching this is like
the most absurd [__] all text if you
just want to give us your order we got
the rest okay this is literally the
dumbest content on the internet right
now dude the jalapeno sauce in the
chicken quesadilla can you cut the
Dancing Yeah
I love this shot
that's a good shot
so Ela wanted the uh fried chicken taco
and the potato taco
okay got it also I want the um [__]
fried chicken I I feel like I can't
decide so I want the quesadilla with
sour cream also and the Doritos taco no
you don't want that I'm copying Evie's
order
[Music]
well quesadilla and then what was the
other one
whatever Abe got okay I gotta move on I
can't I'm so sorry you guys Dan Dan
knows his stuff but he's compromised
he's vegan so you know what I mean I
know that I take that into consideration
um but here's the thing
talk about when are you gonna be [__]
paying us for this [__]
and I'm not talking gift cards yeah
expired gift cards right
I don't know if they're expired probably
000 [__] people are watching us order
Taco Bell you know at least a thousand
of them are going to talk about right
now all right I'm moving on please God
damn
so shout out Martin shout out Gwen uh
what a fantastic night wasn't it folks
yes it was
rip to the goat Paul Reuben
just hit hard
this is Herman I mean God he was a big
part of all of our childhood wasn't he
yes indeed
sucked up that man
did
there's nothing like Pee-wee Herman out
there man that was such an iconic
character
and like weirdly nuanced because Peewee
was like this upbeat lovable guy but
also like a sociopath at the same time
when dealing with people
you know
um such a great character rest in peace
to Paul Rubens yeah died of cancer ugh
he was battling cancer in private for I
think five years it said
I was shocked to find out he was 70
years old too yeah looks good yeah
looks really good
he actually put out a statement too
um upon his
to be put out upon his death what was it
I saw it somewhere
I haven't I hadn't seen that no
ah where is it we'll try to find it and
link it for me but yeah he put out some
kind of statement
but you know a rest in peace he's
definitely jerking off in the big
foreign theater in the sky how about him
he's beating his knee furiously freely
how about it buddy you earned it
that's right
yeah
um
this is great you know we've been
talking about Fouseytube a lot his
stream's been kind of popping off you
guys know he's a friend of the show
and I don't we've been showing a lot of
Clips but this one is just so [__]
funny
I literally can't stop laughing from
this does he really have 30 000 Subs now
that's nuts yep and on uh yesterday he
actually hit 15K live viewers oh oh I am
so happy holy crap yeah
that's crazy it's it's addicting is he
behaving
yeah he he has you know he has his
moments but it's kind of nice because
the audience is supportive of him and
kind of helps him through it
keep it up Lucy
but but watch this watch is so funny
how old are you
dude I've never seen
somebody react that [__] fast dude
that's a winner oh man this one how old
are you
this weekend was wild because he kept
getting into random people's cars
like a lot of them were fans but then
there was like random fans that were
like stream sniping him and it was just
it was a whole Saga wow there's a lot
I'm not getting into random people's
cars man he at one point he thought he
might be getting kidnapped live yeah
live like he was in his he lost cell
phone service and he was afraid that
they cut his phone and he started to
share his location with me so he sent it
to you yeah yeah I don't know if he
knows I still have his location that's
awesome yeah
uh here but luckily no shoes 21 so
you're good okay
like I love he wasn't even doing that
like an ounce of humor that was just
pure
snap
reaction
wait how old are you
it's so [__] good okay
keep it up foosi stay good be good stay
out of trouble all right [__] you
uh that was so funny
how old are you can you grab that Zach
sure wait how old are you
keemstar could learn from fousey man
keep sure I should have dude what does
keep sure think of high school girls
um
just as I thought
yo bro I'm at this high school girl that
I was hot as [__] tonight
ah
so good
uh let's see Elon Musk changed the name
of Twitter to X and I don't know if you
guys are having the same thing but I go
on my phone and I'm looking for Twitter
and I'm scrolling around on my desktop
and I cannot find it and I'm like oh
it's [__] X now this stupid
so dumb dude but if that's not bad
enough imagine living across the street
from his goddamn building in San
Francisco look at this
here it is there's a giant glowing
strobing X
just blindingly bright it's [__]
insane facing a residential building
across the street
um
the uh Kenny Rogers chicken thing
I know a hundred percent even worse
probably and uh
you know
I do have to commit that was fast as
[__] that he got like
a monster-sized strobing x i guess when
you're a billionaire you can make things
happen
and just break all of the laws and don't
care yeah yeah yeah of course well so
there's a happy ending to this story
um but here's a here's a tick tock
screen named Twitter to X he erected a
massive light up Exxon on top of the
company this is Ken Ken clip yeah Ken
clippenstein yeah he's the headquarters
in San Francisco this decision prompted
one Twitter user to post the video
You're Now watching along with a text I
would be livid imagine living across
from that X before panning to the
Residential Building next door within
hours a Twitter user who lives in that
building posted this video from his
apartment Window literally tweeting
imagine no more and this is my life now
about video of the flashing X sign this
follows reports from earlier this week
that the company removed the iconic
Bluebird sign without proper permits or
observing safety measures this is far
from the first yeah who gives all [__]
about safety measure when you're Elon
damn must give me a hand job for a horse
don't worry about it first time most
kids run to follow the rules just ask
anyone at the SEC absurd is this always
there's an important Point here
billionaires like Elon Musk think
they're Above the Law that's true king
that is exactly what it means you know
pop off clip clap clip clap
uh but the sign was taken down this
morning actually uh so [__] him
here it is being removed by the city
because again he didn't get permits he
didn't do safety checks this is just
this is a big government stepping
Stepping Over The Line once again
yo rushing the little man you know just
let me put up my giant strobbing X that
hasn't been inspected could just fall on
Walkers by on the streets explode
set the building on fire uh San
Francisco doesn't have a history of
burning to the grounds not a problem
yeah so Elon Musk continues to be a
douche and I'll be honest I'm using
Twitter less and less I really am
and I'm looking at you threads just give
me a news feed please
they're dropping the ball man
a news feed that's the only reason I go
on Twitter it's for the news feed I I
just subscribed to a bunch of news
people on
uh on the Breads and my whole feed is
that the trending tab the trending tab
is [__] worthless no it just tells me
what's popping dude it keeps my ear to
the to the ground you know what I mean
you know I gotta feel the vibrations
know what's out every time I go on there
lately the trending tab is just like uh
uh Biden
Biden our worded children or something
let's see what it is right now here's
here's a clip of Joe Rogan I guess
people are turning on Jim Gaffigan who
went on Joe Rogan because he is
pro-vaccine oh no yes sir Jim Gaffigan a
community who spread false information
during the pandemic defends Joe Biden
says what a great father he is good news
is Joe Rogan destroys him
several times during the show
that's such a great audience they have
there yeah it's good
why does it lie
I want to watch that clip actually can
you send it to me on
I want to watch Joe Rogan destroy the
Gaffigan [__] you the cake guy
the Hot Pockets guy
Joe Rogan
let's see Joe Rogan oh the top result
it was a quartering
Joe Rogan causes epic meltdown no I
don't want to watch TV yet no I don't
want to watch it's funny that that's the
first result IQ inbred loser my wife
went out for a pizza without me and now
I took a [__] in my bed
I took a grumpy right under her pillow
my wife went out for pizza without me
it's just it's there's tons of Clips on
Twitter if you can send me on Discord
there we go all right let's take a look
at Joe destroying Jimmy boy
Joey Logan explains to Jim Gaffigan why
we don't want pharma-controlled media
okay I don't think the media is
controlled by Pharma I mean I mean the
media is controlled by like okay
whatever Jim did uh stand up routines
and shame people who wouldn't get the
shot all right commercials you know
they're I think they're only legal in
the U.S and New Zealand yeah but New
Zealand's far more restrictive than the
us too but if they got rid of them yeah
there's no context what are they even
talking about this clip sucks is there
another one half our channels I know
they probably would and that probably
they would be good Joe Rogan destroying
Jim Gaffney yeah yeah yeah yeah give me
that one
how does it lie
Jim Gaffigan anyone
is
pretty bad well the January 6th thing is
bad but also oh but we're putting the
cabinet
yeah that's very thick sting is bad but
have you heard of what they've done to
uh Ivermectin uh-oh budgets agencies
were involved in provoking people to go
into the Capitol building that say
[__] what Joe Rogan let me go back
thing is
pretty bad well the January 6th thing is
bad but also the intelligence agencies
were involved in provoking people to go
into the Capitol building that is one
thousand percent
psycho conspiracy [__] right that's like
Alex Jones level
what's the validity of that he says it
like it's known the CIA was was trying
to get people to go into the building
where's that coming from
I mean genuinely what the [__] that's a
fact that's a fact oh
we should have just kept watching so
wait a minute you're you're saying that
that guy
what's his name Ray Epps yeah you really
think that he I don't know I don't you
just said it's a fat dummy fat I that's
definitely a fact in my opinion the fact
no but I do know every other parent I
think he's gonna Sue Fox I think every
other person who was involved in January
6 who was involved in coordinating uh a
break-in into the capital and then
instigating people breaking they were
all arrested this guy wasn't not only
that they were defending him in the New
York Times who's he talking about
who's that
he was a guy he was one of the rioters
and he has become a big Target on the
right because of Mostly because of
Tucker Carlson actually which some
people speculated is why he got fired
because he they're probably going to get
sued for [__] ton of money again yeah
um he was a rioter and he did
participate
um and they've uh glommed onto this idea
that he was an FBI plant and he was the
one like okay forcing them all to go in
there or whatever one middle-aged
[__] goofball Ray Epps he managed to
Galvanize tens of thousands he's so
stupid yeah it's just like he was just
one dude in the crowd and he was on
video being like let's go let's get in
there or whatever and uh I don't know I
love when they turn on their own he's
like dude I love Trump I was there and
they're like no yeah he's a plant
that's crazy Joe that's crazy Joe won't
talk about the actual CIA plant that was
instigating [__] on January 6th by the
way Alex Jones yep you think Alex Jones
is a CIA plant
I do like that theory
it's theories on theories
Fox News is unjustly accused him of
instigating well he clearly instigated
I think the person that instigated was
[__] the president and his dumbass
sons and all the people there speaking
[__] Joe how can you be so obtuse you
dumb [__] get your head out of your ass
talk to somebody who's not like
black pilled uh dumbass Mega brains what
an idiot this guy moved to Texas and he
loses an IQ point every goddamn day and
to be honest he didn't have a lot to
spare to begin with
as the temperature goes up his IQ lowers
it's Global as a result of climate
change my friends
I love I love it dude
random default not the president what
I want a vape what the [__] kind of
logic is that as a Fed I know a lot of
people think he was a fed the people
that were there were calling him a Fed
what I do know is when they asked the
FBI the FBI said we can't tell you
whether or not there were people that
were there that were doing that now of
course they had Undercovers we know
about them the [__] leader of the
proud boys was an informant right it's
it's so stupid
I love that they're just turned on this
random guy itself there's been reports
that there was hundreds of agents that
were there that were doing that I don't
know if that's true either but I do know
it's in fact
damn
today I only want to talk about the fact
so I suppose they're what's their Theory
why does the FBI trying to get people to
charge
so they could round them up and arrest
them
for the outcome that they got yeah and
to make them look bad and I suppose
I suppose the FBI was behind the whole
election fraud thing getting them to
think that they needed to kill Mike
Pence
you know
they probably also were the the guys who
packed up like guns and zip ties
that was the FBI too that they do use
agent provocateurs to disrupt peaceful
protests it's a common tactic what they
do is say if there's a this is insane
this is absolute dribble dude and I
don't use that word very often against
the intelligency this is straight drive
I wish people like um
gath again would stop going on that show
because look look what happens you try
to speak your mind and now you're a
provocateur they're coming for you Jimmy
your hot box Ain't Gonna Save You Now
right this is Joe Rogan's best bud as
you pointed out Dan
like don't you can't you text him
you know Gaffigan was just on um Mark
Maron show and that was a really good
[__] interview yeah nothing about
this [__] [__] yeah like
come on Joe has to Virtue signal because
he's he's
courted this like conservative
Mega leaning uh uh you know audience so
if Jim says something that goes against
their narrative
he has to whatever
anyway X sucks
that's where this all came from
[Applause]
um
something interesting here okay so
actually
we actually working on this new sign to
advertise the podcast in La I don't know
if you guys know this this is the the la
Skyline
new project we're working on
it's it's uh 10 billion volts
it actually is able to provide heating
to all the nearby buildings
raises the temperature by 20 degrees
actually Birds they they die they fall
to the ground if they fly within 100
feet of it good
it's good
you know it also works as a bug zapper
if you thought there weren't enough bugs
weights on this the bugs work or the
Birds work like Icarus where they're all
like Wildlife all Wildlife is going to
be dying
but the people will know it's HP podcast
forever
yep okay this is interesting one of the
one of the island boys who we've talked
about going uh
dabbing their foots into the incest
world
[Music]
has come out as gay and we love that for
him don't what's your argument you're so
fast with that bro
uh here he is this one which one is this
this would be uh Sky Soldier fly Soldier
yep
fly Soldier
that's a good name what about that fly
Soldier junior he supports the flies fly
Soldier Shredder Klein oh wait there's
no audio did the I think the video got
I think Instagram did something to it oh
[__]
damn it uh there isn't any yeah right
maybe you guys can find a replacement
but that's very exciting and we're all
very happy for him
you know it's not the thing is it's not
gay to have sex with your
identical twin brother
it's actually super not gay and so adult
incest
I just I didn't know that he was you
know I didn't know he was gay but I'm
happy for him
yep big surprise
um
you know gay there was a debate in this
office around the meat Mountain
this was a project
we got this in 2022
we encased a meat mountain and resin
and we actually had a bit of a debate in
the office
I said this thing would not
um
it wouldn't rot because there's no
Oxygen for the bacteria to use any you
know what I mean right and I believe
that some of you all said that it would
rot
Dan I think said that
I don't remember
frankly I think a lot of people stood
against me yeah many people you remember
that a lot I remember I might have
honestly thought it would raw well let's
pull it out
let's see this thing oh as you pick it
up I noticed it might have been dropped
at some point
you'll see the edges that looks pretty
preserved yeah yeah it's been dropped
let's go this is fresh yeah this thing
is preserved for all of history to
remember it but
I can't so yeah I mean it's been like
two years and this thing is I mean it's
a meat Mountain yes isn't that [__]
awesome like you could still see
the fry marks you could see the bacon
the bun it's all happening
you know it's beautiful
so there it is if you guys were
wondering if resin can preserve food
it can
thank you we should uh replace the Teddy
Roosevelt statue with that
this is a National Treasure [__] Teddy
Roosevelt
well I was thinking you know maybe let's
crack it open and give it a shot
you can you go right ahead
I mean theoretically it's not it should
be fine right
no no it's covered in uh resin no right
that's probably probably not
theoretically or or in real life
[Laughter]
let's see oh people we've been doing
updates on Twitter this was uh I did
them when I was here last year oh [__]
so this is from March 2022 so it's been
a minute yep
I mean I would say there it looks the
same I would say it looks the same yes
very similar yeah I'll start doing them
again it's even preserved the X on the
bot right that's fantastic know your way
around some meat
yeah it looks identical
but I do wonder you just is this going
to stay the same 10 years 20 years like
are we what kind of are we talking on
the cosmic scale
[Music]
uh if the drop did something because if
you look it's been dropped I'm curious
if that will introduce some
um oxygen oxygen it doesn't look like
there was yeah it doesn't look like it
went all the way in
yeah I don't I think it's I think it's
still preserved okay good good but I
mean you look at um you know
bugs from the the prehistoric era we're
talking 80
82 you know hundreds of millions of
years preserved in Amber
right and I mean this is modern day
amber here we have a meat Mountain and
we could bury this for future
Generations future species frankly it's
the color of your modern day amber yeah
yo one yes this is I like my eyes your
eyes are modern
but um
dude imagine like 100 million years from
now all of humanity is dead we've been
wiped out the Earth has moved on a new
intelligence arises
they dig this up
what do you make of this what is it they
probably try to take it out maybe maybe
they do like a
like Jurassic Park they'll take the DNA
like we did from the mosquitoes in the
Amber and they'll try to bring it to
life
and I believe and it'll be some horrific
hybrid of like six different mammals
that make them all the different
and the meats in there some sort of
chicken pig cow hybrid
it's actually quite tragic in a way like
they they sample the beef and the
chicken and then they just re they re
they revive chicken and beef just to
enslave them and eat them again
that's pretty dark it is dark isn't it
yeah
they're like damn this [__] tastes good
but then
anyway shout out meat Mountain should we
shout out should we maybe put it under
her we should put it area bury it maybe
under the parking lot for a year I I
think so I think that would be cool I
think it'd be cool to do an H3 time
capsule
for the for the kids in 100 years doing
the H3 podcast right the boys my whole
family my whole generation of boys it's
gonna be it's gonna be a business the
thing is I'm not ready to bury it though
because I still want to follow them
right
I've seen several Chatters say that they
feel like they saw mold on it no that's
a lie I don't think so there's no mold I
swear to God people said that when I
posted the updates too and there's no
mold there's no more there's no mold
maybe
um that way on camera or something but
uh
yeah no it's the air it's preserved yeah
it's just air pockets yeah
stop it
yeah stop quit it stop it not a pinch of
mold on it
and I wonder can you still buy the meat
Mountain
uh let me see meat Mountain I remember
even when we did it was a very limited
selection of locations like not every
Arby's even has it
oh it's a secret menu item yeah I see
and Arby's if you are watching I'm also
available for being paid
all resin all your whole menu
that'd be great that'd be a great
sponsor
a resin Taco Bell
a family Taco platter
there's covet in there that's a good
point oh no this has the alpha coveted
oh no
holy [__] dude yo somebody's gonna open
that in a million years and wipe out
their civilization like like the thing
right
it's just
that's awesome that is awesome
uh let's see Ethan's a lying piece of
[__] I talked about this one um see you
next Tuesday but it's worth addressing
here for the public yeah
yeah like Warheads you like Warheads or
no no next up one of mine
Warheads Ethan Eline piece of [__] you
[__] you got me yeah
for the
okay was it worth all the LIE
first of all is it worth all I apologize
for lying I'm deeply regretful
it wasn't okay
and actually I have a little ditty I
wrote for you guys now that I see the
background
the only thing I've uh groomed is my
it's my War I don't know
yeah so
[Music]
the only thing I've groomed are my bag
of warheads I'm sorry I used to wash
them under the water and just eat them
when they're sweet
[Music]
for Atomic Fireballs the toxic gossip
train
Warheads are too sour and I lied about
liking them toxic Warhead train
I like them but only after I wash them
with water the sour Warhead train I
prefer toxic fireballs
you wash up with water then you eat it
and lie to your friends
listen as long as we're having fun
I've been need faking eating Warheads
for 20 years I wash them in the sink and
then come back and pretend like I ate
them [__]
[Music]
all right all right all right so
I kill the reason I lied
I maybe Miss I misunderstood
is that on the snack show
they were asking it was more about
Nostalgia they wanted to unlock the
Nostalgia
now the WarHeads they have a lot of
place and memory in my past and that is
why I brought them and let's be honest
when you wash them they taste great
as long as it's entertaining just as
long as it tastes good to you
so that's why I lied okay I do apologize
though for if I breached your trust if
you could never trust me again
and I apologize thank you
I will uh put out a musical apology in
full [__] me right
that's right
this is pretty funny I guess
some dude falling
yeah this is always good it's College
security guard Khalid is he's a fast
skipper
he's skipping like he is fast skipping
to My Lou my dude that bodyguard he
can't keep up with those monster skips
look at that
boom dude
pretty gracefully though boom dude
what's the hurry why are they running
you left your homie in the trenches
Khalid
no man Left Behind wait there's another
angle if you let this video keep playing
all right I'll take oh just let it play
yeah we got all the angles here folks
JFK that grassy knoll stuff yep yep
shut up little sweet k-16
uh you can really see
look at the skips dude he is fast he is
fast fast frolicking
he's frolicking boom good roll that time
the second one's not as graceful I
believe no Dan would you like to bring
up your theory about Khalid where about
his Renaissance
the part two of the Renaissance
uh are you mixing up College this is the
wrong Khalid my friend I thought you
said DJ Khaled no just no it's just Cali
this is just standard calendar what yeah
yeah there's two khalids there's DJ
Khaled Ain't skipping like that there's
a dyslexia guys read that wrong
not a DJ Khaled this is Khalid [__] me
and he's kind of he busted on the scene
a few years ago so he kind of yeah I
know [__] the kala name is now he's
correct oh now I just feel dumb you like
him I'm not real familiar with his music
he's all of them I mean he left his
homie behind taking grenades I know that
apologies yeah it's okay yeah I was
saying uh DJ Khaled is having a second
Renaissance right right the Cal the DJ
Khaled content online has been pretty
incredible in the last couple he doesn't
miss really I mean he's always not
missed yeah but take the hinges out the
[__] boy's hands I feel like there was a
you know what five six years ago yeah
around that time around the the jet ski
video when he was really peaking on just
like the online cringe yeah uh but it
kind of faded into the background but I
don't know I feel like he's back it's
like when he got lost at sea on his jet
ski his career got lost as well but here
I mean like yeah this is one of the
recent ones this is called what that's
your thing and this is called words and
what is this surgery pickled banana
peppers and what is this
what is this that's water bro
Sunday morning to lead by the way
[Laughter]
that's not laugh he's doing he does it's
almost like um I don't know Sunday
morning Sunday brunch Sunday breakfast
what's happening Khaled
yeah we love that for him though don't
we [__] he's also had a he's been loving
cappuccinos like the color cappuccino
and coffee because he's got a new Rolls
tell him to bring up oh
agree the cappuccino colors is really
classic right so he that's like I
noticed that's his thing now yeah he's
like latched on he got a he got a coffee
rolls yeah that sounds pretty classy I'm
not even gonna lie no it's hype is [__]
yeah
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
the human sound bite right tell him to
bring out the whole ocean
tell them to bring out the whole ocean
tell them to bring out the hole we know
we heard you say that it's just all he
said
don't say it again please
[Laughter]
stop the time Loop dude I gotta pull
that this is so funny
not again don't say it again
exactly the same every time too is this
a sound bite
it's not
another one it is out of control man oh
my God tell him to bring out the whole
world oh yeah it's him
why does he move it so like Suave like
that I need to learn
um a friend of the show by the way yeah
for those of you who aren't long time
Watchers
I actually did a video with Khalid
because you did [__] I haven't watched
that in a minute should we watch it yeah
yes it's pretty entertaining I have not
watched this video
and maybe a decade at the time we were
making a ton of DJ Khaled videos
and there was tons of fun everyone was
loving it
and then there was a radio contest
um in Florida he lives in Miami
and the winner of this radio contest was
something about like the cutest
Valentine couple wins a trip to meet DJ
Khaled
and the fans were like we have to do
this
so we entered we completely rigged it I
mean we we were one with like 10 000
votes and second place had like 50 they
said
and when they called to tell us we won I
was like look just so you know
we totally rigged this so if you don't
want to give it like I just want you
they said well listen it was a we did it
to get attention and you gave us
attention I said okay cool I mean true
so they flew us out
um and it's funny we Khalid almost
canceled on us like we were supposed to
meet him this day and then he canceled
in another day and he canceled busy guy
man and then just to make good on their
promise this the last day they're like
okay you're you're gonna go to his house
just because we he you know what I mean
so we we drove out to his house
God it was so weird dude we were in his
home with this whole all of his posse
and his click and all these people it
was so weird it was being like Willy
Wonka's chocolate factory just seeing
how everything's made we opened up our
Pokemon Go app and we saw DJ Khaled on
the map
in Miami so what we're doing right now
is that we're driving to his location in
the map
so we're hoping to find him
the encounter okay
when you Corner a homogeneous you need
to act cautiously yeah okay I guess the
important I mean we were we were goofing
on him obviously all of our videos were
Goofy on him
I don't think yeah well just say that
but we do have all the special Pokeballs
that are required to capture a Pokemon
of his caliber so master ball forward to
see what happens here guys meet DJ
Khaled oh okay uh what's your name Ethan
Ethan give me one second what's your
name
cool thanks
[Music]
so what's weird is like it's in a
totally like
normal looking residential neighborhood
oh yeah
and I was like where are we right now
um
I had never been in a neighborhood that
looked like that to be fair to be honest
it was like no sidewalk massive Street
tons of grass on all the yards
it was really just felt like I was just
really weird but didn't seem like it
wasn't a rich neighborhood at all
there's a lot what in Florida there's a
lot of neighborhoods like that that are
super random It's So Random like around
where we lived in Florida there are
Believe It or Not R Kelly and Fat Joe
had a house that was like not even a
mile away and it's just random like
residential that's what yeah okay yeah
it's like yeah but I mean the house was
nice and massive it was just like he had
a compound in the middle of like just a
normal residential neighborhood
I was nervous bro I was so nervous what
is our life right now because
yeah I had been goofing on him for a
long time and I suspected that
he might be [__] with us uh-huh
that was my sitting here waiting for
Khalid to give us the thumbs up I don't
know if he knows who we are maybe he's
peeping through like the security camera
right there and he sees my [__]
stupid ass face
all of a sudden it's clicking for him
and that he's giving us no clearance I
don't know what's happening
but I'm nervous very nervous they're
watching me in that camera they think
I'm going crazy they're gonna think I'm
gonna kill him I'm not here to hurt him
dude I just want to put him in a
Pokeball
yes royalty free YouTube music all day
yeah we're sitting here on the couch
[Music]
I'm supposed to talk
in here oh yeah right so they brought us
into his Studio while he was making
music oh wow
and he had just got a verse from like
Kendrick or something that they were
listening to over there
[Music]
I didn't think it was anything
but they we already parked their car and
they closed the gates
it's too late to bounce it's too late to
leave I guess we just have to wait it
out and see what happens find that door
[Music]
I wonder if pit bulls in there that'd be
dope to meet him Little Wayne would be
dope if he's there maybe his boy Ivan
the one who filmed him in the shower
we do meet Ivan actually I think we
could jump the fence
just leave the car oh we were okay we
were at the reception that's where we
were we were sitting there for like 30
minutes
that'd be a clean Escape
finish in the studio invited us to join
him for dinner
um
can you hang out with me in Miami
um and I'm recording my album they gotta
hear some exclusives
so be ready
Miami DJ cattle we the best and I
appreciate y'all coming out here now
thank you you know what I'll say he was
so nice and hospitable he was genuinely
s very sweet very nice
very welcoming so
you know for all the goofing and he was
he was a great he was a very great guy
yes I have dinner now
oh yeah at the time he had oh just
opened his restaurant finger licking I
think is that really what it's called I
think it's called finger licking DJ
Khaled restaurant and he had um the
whole meal catered but not for us this
is what he does every day this is called
the licking
I thought it was finger licking maybe
it's changed it's the licking Orlando
because isn't the licking like getting
your ass beat
from well it could be interpreted that
way and he so he catered food from his
restaurant
and um
it was awesome so this the chef prepared
him a fat plate
he went started eating
before everybody else I just thought it
was funny like they gave him a like real
silverware a real plate
and then he went and started grubbing
down on this massive plate and then for
everybody else it was like a buffet with
paper plates and plastic knives and
stuff and I I just thought it was funny
you know
I mean [__] it's his it's his place you
know what I mean sure it was just funny
merch okay
we had to make our own merch I like that
that's one of my favorite moments yeah
listen you know what's so crazy is that
um
I just scheduled myself to go back to
the Bahamas oh oh same spot and I'm
timing it because you know I got another
number one I got a few more number one
records we're gonna get another Bahamas
yeah
let's go that never happened I don't
think I don't think that happened
it was all downhill for Cal since this
unfortunately
weird but do you not recognize this at
all because we've made like a lot of
videos about you I I
I'm I'm so embarrassed but I had to do
it yeah you had to for the content
totally I was there I had to [__] do
it
like millions of views I probably do you
got Julian for me I'm not gonna lie I
might you know I look it's okay if you
don't yeah
because they have like like we have like
10 million views probably of videos
we've made about you on YouTube well
we're gonna watch them again today okay
okay
it was meant to be for us to meet yeah
yeah I like that I like that how does it
feel to be stupid and finger licking and
DJ Khaled Studio
it doesn't get weirder than this to be
honest
that's that's the famous rice yeah from
celebrating in the Bahamas that's the
race is that Rice wow it's rice dude he
made it
but uh let's get I'm gonna skip that
concern today I love the meatloaf I love
the lobster I love the chicken wings and
I love the red velvet cake the red
velvet cake a problem so this is it this
red velvet this is a crown
[Music]
now what's the perfect bite because I
got a little
it's called a piece of the cake
I gotta say when I watched you eating
finger licking I thought he's
exaggerating
you know I'm gonna tell you something to
keep it means if you ever see me
um promote or anything it gotta be
something I love
you know I mean something I can connect
to or I like
um you know of course you don't get
opportunities and it comes this was like
the only time I have like of him talking
um
at one point and see if you like it I'm
gonna come down to that food
I'm Gonna Keep it strong real my fans
are always asking me to do Snapchat yeah
but I don't I don't get it I feel like
something's missing
can you teach me how to Snapchat it's
all about
it's all about the iconic angles there
you go that's that's what you guys were
talking so on that iconic angle yeah
[Music]
that's an iconic angle like everything
else is gonna be my first snap
yeah
this is reproductions yes and the key is
when you get on a snap you got to put a
good message out there that's it
okay people what up just want to say
special oh we're out of time
so annoying 15 second rule uh this thing
is crazy hey guys continuing my last
snap you see it iconic angle good
message everybody having a good day
amazing having a good day I'm here with
Egypt count iconic candles and dropping
crazy snaps oh so this is
the director of DJ Khaled in the Bahamas
celebrating number one this is the guy
this dude was so there's like this super
iconic uh
a shot of DJ Khaled showering right
[Music]
foreign
I used to use that clip in every single
video about him and then one day they
all started getting like
demonetized or even age restricted right
um damn
[Music]
thank you
you hit it again did you not no but it
was on the screen it doesn't matter if
you hit the button it doesn't matter but
it comes back after I push the button
doesn't it it no because hitting this
button a second time it will
continuously go back and Rewind how much
did we cut out I mean now like almost a
minute oh [__] wait really well every
time it's 20 seconds and and yeah well
but Ian was it on the screen after I
pushed the button it was but it was but
I'm telling you it won't be on the
stream it's all good [__] I'll go back
and double check so I'm double checking
okay so there's this there's a sex scene
of Khalid
like railing somebody
and I showed it I used to I already
explained this but I had to button it
out another one
[Music]
foreign
I've explained this three times and
every time I have to button because it
shows up on the screen again this is the
third time I've explained this
so oh my God and I don't know what got
through so there's this iconic scene
it's just like three minutes straight of
button screens now Okay so
so there's an iconic scene of Khalid
railing a girl
and I used to put in all of our videos
it's great very funny
um was you know was he actually nailing
someone's accent no it was it was fake I
asked Ivan
but it looked real
and um I used to put in all the videos
and then one day all the videos got age
restricted and demonetized so I know
YouTube doesn't like you
now what happened is I explained that
and then I play and then it shows it
again and then I have to do a button
again so this is a third butt or fourth
button I think just three
I skipped for it I don't think there's
any more
so
please let that be the last time I have
to explain that
all right before we left
[Music]
hahaha
I literally I just no more maybe we
should stop watching this
okay okay I did it again it's gonna keep
happening
I don't did they hear anything I've said
yeah probably a little bit yeah this
time it was a long enough Gap that they
heard another one okay so it happened
again because like I said I put it in
all the videos and then the video I was
showing him I showed it again
oh my God can I can I can I tell you
Ian's notes on our side chat because he
notes the buttons he says no at this
time stamp and another time stamp and
then the third one says note to self I
don't even know
okay so like I wanted to okay should we
just bail yes
because it's it's probably gonna happen
again it's probably going to happen
again we're done does anyone know what
happened was there any explanation left
another one all right we're gonna we're
gonna bail on this you guys can go watch
the video oh yeah yeah
I saw it flash on wait no
somebody said they saw it Flash
it's impossible it's impossible right
don't listen to chat
all right thank you DJ Khaled
DJ khaled's Revenge
apparently we did one two three four
five six buttons right now
all right so let's move on quickly
uh here's there's one more thing I want
to do and then I want to do a main
segment which is um
Demi Lovato's family is coming after me
and we've tried to think is there a
reason
what was it that I possibly said about
her that set them off well a Reddit user
was kind enough to put together an
entire list of every time we've
mentioned Demi Lovato what was it that I
said
and I would like to go over every single
one
and I need a full analysis here of why
the lovados are coming for me
the Lovato Clan but in the meantime does
this what do you guys think make of this
I mean this is we talked about these
Alpha training ones where they pay like
fifteen thousand dollars to be abused
powerful Roar of 30 men letting go under
a waterfall just so
just watch it first and then I'll give
you some context
[Music]
that's not even out of place
all right so what's the context so this
is not some Alpha retreat thing no it's
not no it's it's it's a it's a group
therapy kind of thing it actually
sounded very uh wholesome yeah no good I
mean I still laughed at the video
because it's funny to see a group of 30
men screaming at a waterfall
um but it it you know they're doing it
as like kind of like a cathartic uh let
the let the pain out kind of thing well
either way that's what it is but I
actually my my
um reaction was that you know I was like
listen these these guys are actually go
they're clearly going through something
right so let's acknowledge that they're
going through something you know what I
mean and scream at that waterfall and
pound that water
I'm with you bro
sometimes you gotta let it out
okay don't let it out that much
sometimes you got to keep it in too
all right let's talk about the lovados
so here we go the Lovato crime family
that's right so Demi Lovato is the head
of the family as you know Al Capone
uh-huh done
and then I had a hard time the rest of
the week we need like a criminal
organization chart at the head the dawn
oh
Demi Donato
okay
and Below there's two sisters that have
come for me two on Twitter
hi sisters
let's pull those up just for reference
okay because now we are going in Demi I
will find out if I owe you an apology I
will give it to you
but I need to know what I'm apologizing
for to earn it right so here's the here
thank you by the way to um
Waddles JR this is a fantastic that you
actually put this together I mean you
are amazing for this so it goes back to
2020.
uh the first time we goofed on Demi uh
something about a Thanksgiving turkey
let's take a look
Demi Lovato
it's awesome so she's in this ad about
Humane like a Humane turkey ad which
I've been seeing a lot from Peta and
stuff
uh who got meme down by the way I'll
show you guys that next turkeys are
bright social animals who enjoy being
pet
just ask Demi Lovato
cut to Demi Lovato's Instagram
I'm thankful for you all
it's awesome isn't it that is pretty
iconic it's like did we forget about why
about this
my my the only explanation is maybe she
took a picture with a turkey at some
point and then they used this right but
it's that's what I was gonna say right
now whoa like your energy are on the
same wavelength yeah because it's hard
to imagine them
heard not realizing she eats turkey
you know
a sponsor what are they doing Farm
Sanctuary
well she cooked that [__] turkey
she's like hey hey I didn't say just
because I cooked it doesn't mean it's
not social and doesn't like being pet I
like that turkey
you know that was the those were the
ways you would be like I love my animal
and now I'm gonna eat it because it's
cold and I need food there it is so okay
that was pretty I mean that was pretty
minor yeah I doubt that you can't hold a
grudge over that right I would hope not
okay so that one we can we can give a
pass on
and you know once again by the way
here's Debbie's sister just to refresh
those who didn't see I've been seeing a
lot of support for ethic Planet Trisha
paid us lately let's not forget the
things that they have both done to
undermine multiple communities
and I will never forget about what they
said about my sister they are both
horrible human beings [__] them both
okay Madison listen you could say that
about Trisha I won't even argue
but what would I but what did I do God
everyone gasped but I said that
I'm just saying you know what I mean
like she would have at least
you could have you could have a
discussion about that let's just say
that
you know what I mean
but Ethan Klein I mean Paragon of virtue
no controversies around that guy that's
what I mean undermining communities I
only build up communities
Demi is honestly one of the best
vocalists right now
and their music is fire they are doing
Rock now I mean listen they can be both
can be true
and when I call her she I'm pretty sure
I'm
I'm good this is uh they them she her
pronouns
thank you
so Laura Sloan we can definitely you
know
uh
admire her as both an artist and a
yogurt I mean talk about the yogurt
Community who's undermined who so true I
left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt you know what about the
diabetes community
okay so moving on
uh the yogurt situation 2021 this was
the big Scandal who really is so
annoying I don't know anything about her
except this post her documentary was
great and like you know everyone was on
her side because she struggles with
drugs and you're like okay this is like
good but now it's like oops sorry
okay yeah we all got struggles lady so
uh Demi Lovato Lovato Lovato she said
I'm finding it extremely hard this is
some Karen ass [__] to be honest yeah I
found it extremely hard to order from
Froyo from this place the fact that she
tagged them is like it's demonic I mean
why are you trying to ruin these people
first like the most when you have to
walk past tons of sugar-free cookies and
other diet foods before you get to the
counter do better what is she what is
she mad about diet culture vultures what
is she mad about she's mad because it
triggers her because she had an eating
disorder okay so what the world needs to
organize around you but like so what get
the diet food I don't understand the
fish no she's saying she diet food
should not even exist because it's
promoting like eating disorders and
telling people to be skinny that's so
crazy it's crazy yeah okay so so again
again we were far from the only people
talking about this
yeah it was uh it was all over the news
I mean that being said right now all
this bunch of Articles from when it
comes when this happened hello we did
have how many views does this this has
5.4 million views
I know Frenemies was [__]
top and race I know it's crazy man
it is crazy
um
so here's yogurt joke number one let's
see
and actually they do Demi Lovato just
did that last week right right actually
yes apparently Demi Lovato does do that
but your analogy is horrible because fat
people if being fat is not contagious
I left that yogurt store and didn't get
the yogurt that I wanted right well that
is a time yeah
and then I had a hard time the rest of
the weekend right
I'm so sorry that happened to her bam
it's so tried my heart has been bleeding
for her
so again pretty tame I again I'm not
sure what's happening
you know yogurt yogurt joke number two
Demi Lovato
let's review here
okay first of all shout out to ever put
this together is clearly like a
Frenemies connoisseur like holy [__]
Demi Lovato ladies and gentlemen on the
billboard she uh
she her rumor has it she's still upset
about the yogurt incident
her day is still ruined folks we feel so
we we're Hearts go out to Demi Lovato
damn vicious dude you know it's not that
bad vicious yeah he's just why are you
coming for me what did I do you went
right for the jugular Ethan
uh here there's another one oh yeah I
waited two minutes and I and it ruined
my whole day
I mean the real [__] here is this
tweet
I had to well this is like my
this is like Peak I look like Peter
Griffith
what the [__]
that's wild yo what's the date on this
uh
uh okay it's really you know I couldn't
really see the difference but now
now you got it
looked like a damn
I'm not gonna do it you look beautiful
yeah beautiful yeah
holy smokes though
okay that was just in disbelief I mean
how can you there's so much extra faces
yeah it's like a lot of face you're
svelte now
thank you
still have a long long way to go my it's
slowed down a bit I'm still going in the
right direction though
yep 195.
but we're still going we're still in the
right spot
well I was like okay he mentioned his
girlfriend for no reason like obviously
he's just trying I don't think about I
think that was it that's just an
offhanded comment about her because
we're talking about Tim Poole in this
clip okay yeah that's it yeah you just
compared him to the yogurt incident I
just got lost staring at myself
I had another the only other people in
the shop there's there's another mystery
store and didn't get the yo
Demi Lovato knows quite well not getting
the ice cream I had a hard time the rest
of the week they can [__] your whole
week hold on there's a dude in the
background yeah is that it it's probably
it Demi use please provide me some
receipts before you come at me that hard
listen Demi might not want this people
like that dude if both of her sisters
are publicly speaking out
you're a piece of [__] she's coming
that's this is Demi Puppet Master it's
racketeering they're laundering her
opinions for her I see we'll get her on
her RICO charge absolutely she said he
ruined her whole world we're gonna get
the yogurt she wanted more time the rest
of the week if I read that I think it
was a parody but
yeah so I don't think there's any of
this yogurt stuff now the next one
abducted by aliens I seem to recall you
being a lot harsher the poot father
all right
I pooped I pooped hi Demi hi girls
we love you girly just love you just
Goofs okay you're the greatest we'll get
you from the basement soon all right
abducted by aliens let's see this was in
2021 as well they were newborn Demi
Lovato abducted by aliens is pretty
awesome
she's she is rocketing up my my list of
the most hated famous people you're a
terrible person Dan
by the way just uh um just to um Dan
starts if I think we were a little rough
I remember
just to um
contextualize this a bit Ryan Kavanaugh
Accused by ex-partner of running a Ponzi
scheme that was alleged and retracted
oh true Yeah by variety buy buy variety
yeah and retracted but not actually
deleted or unpublished it was a tiny
little annotation I think go read it
yourself
get all the facts yeah it's better to
read it yourself don't take my word for
it Dan is the queen you can't do nothing
wrong all right so let's see what Dan
had to say about uh the poor unfortunate
Demi Lovato I mean she's just a little
kooky isn't she I mean the yogurt
situation the yogurt thing but and then
I had a hard time the rest of the
weekend no yeah I get it
well so Demi Lovato of yogurt Fame
oh so Demi uses they them so I will uh
respect that there you go I already
stepped in it I'll try to wait I thought
I was being respectful
yeah well I might slip up just because
I'm a boomer and I'm not used to saying
it like that what I thought of this is
respectful isn't it
I don't know I was just oh you're just
saying okay Josh or my undermining uh
the community I don't know what that
means no you're saying that you're gonna
I'm trying you're gonna use them and
I've gotten a lot better since then I'll
tell you that I agree with that thank
you Demi Lovato
from yogurt Fame
went to she was in the news recently for
going he already [__] it up oh my God
Demi Lovato went to the yogurt store
and Demi got she they didn't have the
yogurt they wanted yeah
I'm not being funny I'm trying I was
genuinely still managed to do it again I
I genuinely am not trying to be cute or
something
I know it is yeah thank you
I'm trying my best you respect that
you're trying and uh Demi
uh they did not have the yogurt they
wanted
and they tried to cancel the yogurt
store go ahead Zach and then I had a
hard time the rest of the weekend it
ruined
so where does this go I mean where am I
where are we going oh this is the
abducted by ants okay I'll keep
listening Rowan Demi's entire weekend
okay
tragic well truly tragic yeah wow uh
Demi has gone on the Kelly Clarkson show
Clarkson Clark Clarkson you got it bro
are you are you the host of a show like
what the [__] is this are you actually
like talk for a living
[Applause]
Jesus Christ man get it together that
they've been abducted by aliens so this
is Demi's new thinker yeah um I had a
night where I was dreaming and I say
dreaming very Loosely because oh
they were dreaming yeah that sounds like
I don't really know
sudden was in my room and and I know I
said I so I I I said
[Laughter]
with me so I woke up in my room and
there was like three beings and then and
they they
do you want to see your planet and I was
like
sorry
well I was like hell yeah let's go so so
I like whooshed out of my room and was
like hovering over the planet and then
all of a sudden they're like you want to
see our planet and I was like hell yeah
yeah it sounds like a really cool dream
you had when you were sleeping
telling stuff like pink and purple
planet that I've never seen but
and so that was the hypnotherapy I was
like trying to figure out what exactly
that was was it like I don't want to use
the word abduction because that implies
that it wasn't with consent I was
totally used for it it was a it was a
girls trip
it wasn't an abduction
oh this is funny I mean come on it's a
little silly girl you gotta give us that
you know what you said hell yes
so I can't call it like an abduction I
called it an astral projection for a
long time because I went somewhere else
yeah but then I realized maybe this was
just an encounter that I had and I talk
about that we actually have photos of
the of the planet they visited
um Planet yogurt in fact oh no see that
that was below the belt
maybe that's what they were talking
about it's real harsh
[Music]
Planet yogurt though they finally got
that yogurt and that's that's why Demi's
so happy
that's awesome is that it I mean I
probably probably yeah
abducted by aliens sound bite tournament
uh oh oh okay well Demi Lovato had an
Infamous story this year
the yogurt store didn't have the yogurt
she wanted and it ruined her whole week
as you know uh they wanted this is the
soundbite tournament yeah so this is
just recapping it again I don't know
on the sisters by bringing this up and
now we're reviewing every single thing
we said about Demi Lovato
yeah they may regret
doing that
I might might listen uh let's reach out
to the sisters they might like a little
back and forth situation yeah it's all
in good fun okay so here's interesting
one a caller calls in and says I've been
too hard on Demi
so this is this isn't maybe it was one
of her sisters who wants to argue with
Ethan being too hard on Demi Lovato I by
the way this clip is exactly shows why
the Collins were such a disaster the
Collins were such a disaster for this
show
here
[Laughter]
I mean
she's still recovering from the yogurt
shop and then I had a hard time the rest
of the weekend
maybe I'll talk to Adriana who wants to
talk about she I have a problem with fat
shaming Adriana what's what's my problem
talk to me
uh Ethan I've been a fan for a while I
actually came from Trish and started
watching you guys thank you
um I've been struggling with like my own
body image for a while so I guess just
I don't know maybe I'm a snowflake
especially after listening to the last
conversation I was like hmm maybe it's
not even close to what I should be
debating but um yeah I don't know I
think I don't know you verbally like
frown upon it I think and I think
there's a lot of like young viewers
especially like people that are
developing into their bodies so I think
it's just important to be aware of that
stuff are you who do am I fat shaming
myself or someone else
this is about fat shaming where's the
Demi Lovato code putting your own body
into John is not necessarily the best
thing either so wait wait who am I fat
shaming
okay
yourself okay so you're talking about my
my open deprecation of myself for being
fat is not healthy for people to miss
getting calls from uh from the viewers
like this
compelling stuff I know and and the
thing is like
I really like to control the pace and so
when they start to go what I feel is too
long I can be rude or dismissive and
it's just it doesn't come off it's not a
good it's never been a good interaction
yeah maybe a couple yeah we had a few
good things positive things come out of
it but but you know I don't like being
rude or short with the fans you know
what I mean and then it's just doesn't
look doesn't feel good either oh good
luck
so there it is okay that one's uh I
don't understand that one
true jokes about the last caller being
Demi Yoshi did sound just like Demi
Lovato
I swear oh is it wrong it was the wrong
uh timestamp here sensitive for the show
you know I know but I hope like you know
no offense it's okay it's okay to be
found that's the same girl I listen but
you can't stop me from hating myself I
mean I'm sorry but that's just never
gonna happen yeah I'm not gonna yeah
it's just I'll try not to Fat shame
others but you can never stop me from
fat shaming myself okay
all right I love you Ethan I love you
guys thanks
everyone I love you too take care bye
love you you're the greatest but it's a
different call
yeah
okay here
talking about that
um Okay so
so um it's such because you were just
talking about fat shaming doesn't it
sound like Demi right so dude it's 100
one of her sisters
she was
annoyed that
diet stuff was at the front of the store
and so she left because she's like she's
been fat shamed her entire life dude it
sounds just like her when she said life
yeah I heard that that's nuts wait let
me use that yogurt that's nuts he's like
she's been shot shamed her entire life
dude that is Demi Lovato way to go back
I felt this I felt the same thing you
did the earth just shook and so she left
because she's like she's been shamed her
entire life and I had a bad time the
rest of the weekend or her sister it's a
Lovato it's a Lovato
more sense wait this is the Lovato man
[Music]
if I've ever heard one it's a very
unique sound the placement in the throat
yes
maybe not Don Lovato but maybe sister I
think maybe a de la Garza yeah gaming
now is having diet food well also I
don't think it was diet food I think it
was like for diabetics it was like
sugar-free [__] right but she did not
realize that that's why she made the
apology okay I mean the way she said
apology that was a Lovato also the
giveaway is who else would call and make
this argument would her sister call her
she
maybe because it wasn't that oh I think
at this time maybe they just used them
um I think did she ever say that her
family called her she
let me ask probably the reason why yeah
there was something about an ant like
manty Auntie or something dude that
would explain why she's so angry the
girl who tweeted it has to be her
another theory from chat is that maybe
it's Pooh oh it's like nope who can't
talk like that oh Poo is like poop's not
that literate
who lives in a cave and eats raw fish
from the basement
Sasha hold on I really gotta I gotta
break something down
is what
Sasha I mean what is this
video that I said it's Sasha so it's
also Sasha
yes Sasha
all right forgive me forgive me oh no oh
that's sad what happened you're so okay
I understood the story but I think we're
seeing it differently this guy was so
cool what happened Atlas Cloud yeah how
did he die his uh dad died last week and
his family released a statement saying
that he was really struggling oh no
you just called him Atlas Cloud I did
yes oh Angus Cloud which is the
rearrangement of the film and book Cloud
Atlas wait oh he was so cool he was it
seemed like he was doing so good I
really liked him they're going threes
man
what'd you say they go in three
celebrities Paul Rubens oh this guy and
one more
uh Angus Cloud Famous from Euphoria has
died at his family's home in Oakland
the family tells us it is with the
heaviest heart that we had to say
goodbye to an incredible human being
today artist friend brother and son
special to all of us
last week he buried his father and
intensely struggled with this loss the
only comfort we have is knowing Angus is
now reunited with his dad dude what the
[__] this is really sad
English was open about his battle with
mental health and we hope that his
passing could be a reminder to others
that they are not alone
dude what the hell that is so tragic
so sad
man who's 25.
sad no matter what I watched I was a fan
of this show I mean I watched all the
episodes I like this show
and uh I specifically really liked him
yeah I thought he had like the whole I
mean he had the whole world ahead of him
yeah
[__]
that's a shame
oh that's sad
rip to a to a young
talented guy
official cause of death was not
immediately confirmed according to TMZ
the first Ella to report to death on
Monday
TMZ of course
um
wait Mike Malik knew him
seems that way
unless that's Pee-wee Herman
doesn't look like him
oh no
damn bro
hmm
there it is
check on your loved ones people
you know
anyway
uh back to Demi Lovato
[Music]
should have waited to the end to read
that
let me talk about or something
[__] yo how why is it taking so long for
that Taco Bell right now no Zach don't
play the Bell
too soon for the bill you said Taco Bell
it was a Taco Bell all right yeah okay
close one yeah here from Sarah comment
said Demi wants Demi fans bullied a
journalist I know into privateing his
Twitter for the first time in his career
for a critical review he wrote for her
RS
he wrote for RSO Rolling Stone made fake
tweets to look like he mocked her OD
that they're crazy
I am tripping about this sounding like
crazy having diet food is fat shaming
kind of I mean [__] let's just talk what
this is a real person saying having diet
food is fat shaming it has to be her
talking about diet culture you know it's
[__] everywhere and and then she says
diet culture and then in the Tweet she
said diet culture vulture
well there's lots of that's like the
buzzword yeah
you're her mother
I've watched her doc that could be her
Mom it sounds very young though The
Voice
hold on
I'm gonna see if I can get a video of
her mom speaking
I assumed your entire life like since
like I was having someone said the Taco
Bell now
it's good
pretty good I eat food you know how is
having diet food fat shaming you I just
I can't I can't understand that people
think it's Demi I swear to god dude it's
crazy well again she didn't realize it
was a diabetic thing okay forget about
that let's just assume how do you know
that she didn't realize it was a
diabetic thing how do you know
because it's Demi [__] Movado I'm
talking to
but even if even if in Demi I'm talking
to you now because clearly you're
watching
even if it was
even if you didn't know as a diabetic
thing you're still a dick you know what
I mean because you're you're you took
your ignorance for granted and dogpiled
on this yogurt shop dude I swear to God
this is her and what let's die what
makes it a diabetic thing other than
just being sugar-free well because it's
not because there's people that aren't
about diets that want to have sweets and
don't want to try and that's the case
for like
all things that are sugar-free so you're
saying how did she not know was a
diabetic thing yeah like that's
kind of it's silly yeah it's silly
my argument she is newly sober or was
when she made the post right I'm newly
sober too you know I'm going on like
she's she's there's too many parallels
nearly sober I'm also newly sober
really and what is your name Sasha
foreign
a fakest name ever Sasha
holy [__]
Eli oh Olivia's checking her name
against uh her mom
there's hard stuff and for the first
like five years I purposely gained
weight I said I'm not going to think
about anything other than like being
happy
and so I feel like you know we were on
the same level and so like she's perfect
she's she's purposely gaining weight
dude
she's way too spiritually aligned with
Demi got it I just understood why she
made it it's just so stupid what 10
second post right no but the effect of
her post was that she she like called
this place out by name and sent like a
mob of hate because they dared to have
Diet food that's that's crazy how was
having diet food fat chains he has like
a tiny twinge more of an accent than
Demi does and so does her mom can we
listen to her mommy yeah it's uploading
right now okay okay okay okay
it's a product that some people consume
crazy she didn't she can go [__] get
the normal [__] just walk by it I mean
if you're gonna get offended by diet
food how can you exist in this world how
can you even breathe without being
offended by the sunshine because you're
pale I don't understand that how can you
live your life being offended by diet
food that seems it takes you way too far
on her considering dude I it has to be
it has to be her or someone in her
family this is this is unreal you guys
somebody out there Demi Lovato
detectives you guys need to like crunch
the numbers and check the sound waves
and stuff
it's her sister they both recently got
into sobriety together it's got to be
someone in her family I'm reading the
comments dude it sounds exactly like her
bro
maybe understand was saying you know hey
like can we just chill it with the diet
[__] you know well I think people
were mostly pissed at how she like sent
a horde of hate on this tiny little
mom-and-pop story also I'll say
listening this call I think I'm being
really fair and reasonable with this
caller if it is Demi or the family
member I don't you know I mean I don't I
wouldn't hold a grudge for this
conversation it seems like I'm being
patient and fair with a relatively silly
point of view here
[__]
you got that Mom thing Olivia it's at 15
checking what why is it so slow oh it's
checking for claims I see I see
oh my God bro it sounds just like
okay so let's see discussing a tweet
from Demi
wait what is this Demi Lovato somebody
who just sent this or who found this
about to put the airline
[Music]
Is that real no no that part is edited
in the meme
that's [__] hilarious okay that's
just a goose they couldn't be mad about
that okay it says no restrictions right
away send me that link okay
all right so we're gonna listen to
Demi's mom
um is there a video of her sister
talking
she was in her documentary so I assumed
so but I didn't I can look for it after
there uh discussing uh okay here it is
here it is thank you Olivia you just
have to listen for like five seconds
back to that morning when you guys that
your daughter because this is like an
emotional thing this is her okay thing
to talk about
um
I literally start to shake a little bit
when I start to remember what happened
that day and I do remember you texting
you're not wrong I know there is
something to that but I know but the
fact that they all have similar voices
even speaks to the like but this this
has to be her if I'm if I may say her
mom sounds a little more nasally but
it's on the phone that that's true too
that is true hold on let me pull up
can you do me a favor cam
yep okay let's pull a clip of her
talking from this video
and then a clip from that caller
and let's get them side by side so we
can hear them one and then the other on
it get Demi talking and then and get her
mom talking and then it if you can find
anything of the sisters too that'd be
great uh yeah I can look for those two
okay I'll send them to you Cam okay
we're getting we're going to the
laboratory on this one yes we're gonna
see inside this [__]
what is that music Zach it's like
X-Files crime it was play it
it's not the actual X-Files no I know it
just wasn't giving me that Vibe oh
maybe it's just I can't hear it
yo people
do it can we do a poll like I genuinely
I don't think I'm being crazy
it is this Dem someone in Demi's family
I really think it's her mom I is this a
Lovato is this it or no no
dude
also if it is awesome we would like love
to me let's talk apparently you guys
hate me [__]
people are saying I think it's their
sister I think it's her mom that's nuts
is this a Lovato
be honest though don't blow smoke up my
ass and just vote yes unless you really
mean it dude
87 yes
86 yes
we never see positives that commanding
get this to the media
[Music]
call the presses for real oh God like
this is big dudes
you know be a Vibe if Demi came on the
show and we could go out to a yogurt
store and do the interview there that
would I agree
just as a way of coming full circle
that's 86 yes
holy [__]
wow
rating Demi as cringe but harmless
oh what is this one the fake article
Demi Lovato fatty fan claims Lovato
called her fat bulliger but
one of my favorite internet stories is
this a real article
I this was probably published before
they realized that it was fake okay so
it's a fake and we say it's fake nothing
wrong with that
um and then raiding Demi as cringe but
harmless Demi Lovato
um she's not an enemy of the show I mean
cringe but harmless yeah that's if
that's that's a good category that's a
great rating that's that's that's that's
amicable
cringe but harmless
uh put Lovato PowerPoint this may have
do you think dummies mentioned poop
before finally she doesn't care about
the poot I don't think so she yeah no
she doesn't care about the poop and
you're really gonna get upset when I
look like this
been in the works for weeks now that's
ethu yeah this is a segment we have meme
history
the great memes of history that you may
have missed or you may like to be
refreshed on that's right poot
this is a pretty long segment but
phone we even debunked it though we said
it's a the poot is fake yes
so what could it be
well one really valuable thing came out
of this we joked about it when it
happened that it sounded like her
but it is actually her or someone in her
family
it has to be
the poot is strong with them
wow
wow man
[Music]
can we tweet at them from the show the
two girls who tweeted at me from the
podcast just tag them and be like ladies
I would like to apologize to you and
your sisters and your whole family
Let's uh let's connect
over some full sugar yogurt
or whatever type of yogurt your heart
desires
can we actually do that I would love I
think that's an awesome idea let's tweet
at them because this is real
and then as cam works on that I guess
we'll move on to another topic here but
legitimately how long is this Taco Bell
take to deliver I mean
Lena is looking into it I don't know
what's taking so long she's on the she's
trying to call them right now how long
has it been it's been like two hours
has it been two hours
I don't think it's been that long but it
says it says
expected 3 30 to 3 40. okay so that's
like right now
Let's see we were discussing talk about
orders at
uh it was like uh 2 159
it was like around two o'clock it's been
an hour and a half
anyway
I'm sure that food's gonna taste good
nice Taco Bell sitting for two hours
oh yeah
all right let's talk about um
Let's do an Ariana follow-up
we had a fantastic show
I thought on Friday a
phenomenal show Olivia brought out
the big guns the Ariana PowerPoint
and I was quite surprised personally
by some of the reception to it there's a
group of people out there who
hate Ariana Grande apparently they
[__] hate her
and the reason and well they they I
think they shared their hatred I
unfairly
with Olivia
um oh they they they accused you of
being a
a sellout and Ariana uh maybe Stan bias
yeah first of all before it started I
stated my bias that existed secondly I
never defended what she did what she did
was literally disgusting and horrible I
just kept saying oh my God I can't
believe that this is real yeah I don't
think you were saying this didn't happen
you were just shocked as a fan of hers
and I was like playing up the denial
maybe for comedic effect I did not feel
that in any sense you were defending her
thank you in fact I mean the whole damn
presentation was very critical of her
I mean yeah if I if I was trying to
defend her I just wouldn't have done it
you know
and some people were like no she left
out stuff about people cheating and
I did talk about it towards the end but
there are just like there are different
stories so it's like do I really want to
talk about whether or not she possibly
got with someone when they were on a
break from a relationship versus like if
they were actually fully broken up at
the time like no that's kind of boring I
don't really want to talk about it like
I want to talk about SpongeBob there
were a few things that came up
interesting that we can supplement on
but I can't emphasize just how weird
people were about this in the comments
it was like
she's a she's an Ariana apologist she's
such a hypocrite yeah and it's like
chill you guys you know what I mean and
it was Olivia's birthday weekend you
bastards literally no I just stopped
looking that's good
I was gonna message you about it and
check on you but it was your birthday
and I was like I might bring this up it
was very kind Elia did she did oh that's
sweet I didn't want to mess you on your
birthday make you think about that no no
but everything was totally good okay
good and Ela made me feel very loved
that's nice I didn't know she did that
good for her sweetheart but
um
yeah someone made a good analogy it's
like
when when Ian was in his Kanye uh
Awakening
is almost like what Olivia's going
through now with Ariana Grande is that
possible
I mean Ariana did something horrible
but yeah it does seem that there is a
track record of her doing horrible
things one thing that stuck out to me
that I totally forgot was the donut
incident
now this is from 2015. how old was she
then
she's not that old right she must be
she was about 22.
that donut okay okay I mean
should know better
so she was filmed
on a camera at this donut store being
like a total douche
uh and also she made this really funny
apology but here's everything
um
here I am apologizing to y'all oh to be
fair it's giving Travis Scott and nobody
died
also her apology video
play after her
with surgery
you know everything I know
so what does that mean she just started
starts the video by saying like I think
they cut it out of this clip but she
starts her apology saying like I'm sorry
I literally just got wisdom tooth
surgery but like I want to do this right
now okay
um here I am apologizing to y'all
behaving poorly that you have no idea
was taken is such a rude awakening that
you don't it's like you don't know what
to do I was so disgusted with myself I
wanted I'd like shoved my face in a
pillow and wanted to disappear
all right so I guess I don't know what
that means she's in a donut store they
brought a fresh tray of donuts and she
said I hate Americans
paste
but you're right in a donut store no I'm
just kidding
I I don't really get it
I'll get it but that's not it that's not
all that happened
I think it's possible a donut was
decorated like an American flag but I
might I hate America I think she's like
oh my God that's huge I hate America
that doesn't bother me
what happens is worse dies for my Donuts
it's been rough
but um you know
mistaken on being judged for it
so she licks a donut
on display that's
yeah it's [__] up that's weird
it reminds me you remember when people
were going in the grocery store and
licking ice cream and putting it back
that was the [__] worst that's what
she's doing she's doing that yeah it's
gross
that's like the worst oh he that's like
the worst edgy dumb teenage [__]
ever
this is like death to all teenagers
stuff
button
um
no more fun yeah I mean I'm just to all
Jews that's way worse yes
that works
so she did she they were licking the
donut which is pretty vile
you know what I mean
okay so there's donut gate from when she
was 22. right
which is bad
it counts for something I guess
um what was there uh this was part of
the criticism that this was not included
yeah it was yes it was included that
relevant I agree yeah well they beg to
differ so what I I don't think the
presentation
uh specifically suffered for not right I
don't think it necessarily would have
benefited from this inclusion I mean
it's a funny part I guess so this part
though
this was about the amount of times that
Ariana Grande
broken up relationships bit taken taken
men and so this is I think relevant in
very relevant right in terms of what
we're talking about sure so let's watch
this and then you can talk about it uh
right there's a there's another video
that like counters this video just so I
included everything okay so here is
but this photo is so [__] funny I
don't know why it's literally seared
into my brain
they're so bleached
the Dude Looks Like a worm with a face
on it like an earthworm these are
Earthworm Jim
I don't know what that means
you've seen this
not that's not Ariana Grande I don't
love her
right make that clear very clear
all right so here we go Grande aren't
her long history cheating in
relationships
2013 High Brooks accuses is this
unclaimed there was no claim no thank
you appreciate you guys
so Rihanna for cheating on him with
Nathan Sykes
same year 2013 rumors started going
around that Mac Miller and his longtime
girlfriend Nomi broke up because he
cheated on her with Ariana
in 2016 Naya Rivera revealed in her book
that Big Sean allegedly cheated on her
in 2014 with Ariana when she walked into
her house and Ariana was there
in 2018 Mac Miller's ex-girlfriend Nomi
revealed on Her Tumblr blog Mac cheated
on her again with Ariana in 2016.
in 2018 there were rumors Ariana cheated
on Mac with Pete Davidson while Pete was
in a relationship with Cassie David in
2020 Kazi said this does look pretty
demonic the track record is questionable
in Cassie's book she literally says that
okay hold on hold on let's get through
this and then get the bunk at all
she found out Pete was cheating on her
with orianna through Instagram
in 2019 TMZ reports that Ariana and Big
Sean were getting cozy in the studio
together while he's dating Jean Aker in
2020 Dalton Gomez's ex-girlfriend posted
this on her Instagram story when you see
your ex with the person they told you
not to worry about that is that I was
very compelled by I hadn't seen that oh
you had it that I will say I was moved
in 2020 Dalton uh Gomez ex-girlfriend
posted this on her Instagram fueling the
rumor that Dalton cheated on her with
Ariana fueling the rumors that Dalton
cheated on her with Ariana
in July 2023 it was announced to Rihanna
and Dalton are getting a divorce Ethan
Slater and dude I mean look at all this
it's like she it's easy to assume that
she has the thing for breaking up
families that like it turns her on or
something or makes her feel powerful
because why else would she want to [__]
this dude Okay so
100 I believe when when girls
participate in like knowingly taking
other girls Partners it has to be that
like they just want to be they want to
prove to themselves that they are the
hottest and best woman and they could be
they could literally take any they could
have anybody that they want they're
trying to like fill some sort of like
craving that can't be filled and won't
be filled and like she'll just dump him
later and then she'll find another
grandpa with a family that's what I see
if all this is true I mean it's like
really psycho like really 100 freak [__]
I feel the same way comment section I
also hate this
his wife are separating
and now it's announced to Rihanna and
Ethan are dating all in one week fueling
the rumors they cheated she [__]
SpongeBob you guys
okay so so what's your retort to this so
I included another video that I had seen
before the presentation and I was just
like oh okay so I I guess I won't really
mention it because the details are fuzzy
and Naya Rivera debunked that herself
and it's and she was like no I literally
walked in and she was sitting on a couch
and they were working on their duet that
did come out a few months after that
okay so here is the Ariana Grande stand
to the rescue let's see what he said
right and he is biased by the way okay
well both of them you know what I mean
facts are facts let's see what he says
that they're still married with spread
by journalists at paychecks who
notoriously does not like Ariana Grande
so that one she [__] up on like you
can't even argue on that one dummy I
wasn't listening to that yeah that come
on
well also the wife I think came out
publicly it was like they cheated yeah
yeah yeah
a lot
uh why do you care about her dude you
don't even it's like why do you care
earn a list at paychecks who notoriously
does not like Ariana Grande step further
by the way she's like yeah page six
doesn't like her okay
that's just like your opinion dude just
spell the homeworking rumors Cassie
David wrote in her book that she broke
up with Pete making him single
before he went and dated Ariana Grande I
feel like this guy would lie to defend
her do we know that's true he would I
mean that first take is so stupid
you know maybe
clarified that Big Sean did not I know
about her when Pete Davidson tells the
story of how they met it's that scooter
knew that he was in the like down in the
dumps because Cassie broke up with him
and um she he knew that uh Ariana
thought he was cute okay
but um
Cassie claims in her book that she was
fearful to end things with Pete due to
sensitive state of his mental health but
decided to initiate a break because she
was unable to convince him that she
loved him and that was in March and they
got together in May okay or maybe April
so we can debunk one of the there was a
lot let's see with Ariana Grande she
walked into them sitting on a couch
listening it's also just like I know
that this stuff is like relevant slash
compelling but it's like
is it important enough to include in
like 45 slides of this situation that
I'm actually telling you guys about
hey you're telling a story you got to
keep it a little bit focused I do think
the the history is interesting yeah I do
too but the blurriness of it and also I
will say my bias maybe is the reason why
I didn't include it uh subconsciously
and I apologize and we're showing it now
like you said you disclosed a bias and
you're and I also said this stuff at the
end right right that's true we did talk
about like sorry guys yes it also
doesn't [__] matter at all thank you
so much thank you so much just just
pointing that out thank you talking
about celebrity gossip on a comedy
podcast excuse me Dan oh wait back it up
a little bit do not despair the
seriousness of this show sir aha blast
time
that is the queen did anyone get full
Baja Blast or is it all diet oh I'm full
baby okay why are you I'm afraid that
mine why are you [__] me up with this
diet culture [__] sorry bro I just
want to make sure that this is diet
this one definitely has sugar I'll tell
you that okay
on summer 2014 right when they put out a
song together never said
yeah never said he cheat
s and they were working on their duet
thank you
they were what they were working on the
duet that came out at that time okay
all right let me see what it was just
like oh is that important
those Jay Brooks for threatening her and
telling her that if she didn't come back
to him he was going to make her look bad
to the whole world starting she did
tweet on him but she did not here's a
video of what argon has to say about
being accused of being those rumors that
they're still even with all this
she still has done it enough times where
you're like it's enough where it's like
weird but it's also like can you fault
someone for dating someone after they
dated someone else
I see what you mean does she have a
moral obligation to Cassie Davidson to
not hook up with P because they were on
a break no that one's [__] yeah that
one sounds like and that's like her most
recent I didn't see the Dalton one until
today which is crazy it does seem like
there's enough propaganda on both sides
yes people that hate her and people that
stand her that it is a little iffy right
and I maybe I should have put this video
in it you're right well we don't need to
speculate I mean the conclusion is the
same
I agree yeah the conclusion is the same
Ariana Grande did something horrible and
disgusting
and so did that man so Arya is Ariana
like um
permanent L for this she canceled
I don't know
how any of her fans are gonna look at
her
it's just like pretty scummy that's
crazy that you did that and that you
know that all of us know that you did
that mm-hmm
I think people still listen to your
music but
I think people always think of her as
like a scum yeah
by the way also
rip what Naya Rivera
she died a few years ago
that is the woman who said that she
walked in on Ariana sitting in the
camera
sorry guys I'm trying my best not to
chew into the mic I promise
we got the video from cam on the Demi
Lovato crunching yep thank you Olivia
for helping me oh thank you
here's a new article wait Ian you're an
Ariana Grande stand too aren't you
I that I completely forgot to call on
you
oh wait I think the Taco Bell's here
wait I gotta go get my taco from Kanye
to Ariana
well I've been real quiet I haven't seen
her uh say anything about Hitler yet so
far
that's true different scale she's in the
the yellow zone it's not full red alert
Defcon all right
wait till she she's got a
wish genocide on a minority yeah
prejudice
he's still far off from that
although if you ask people in the
comments they might disagree that's what
I'm saying
there's a headline from yesterday Ariana
Grande giving boyfriend Ethan space to
work things out with his estranged wife
dude that's so iconic so he broke them
up and she's over it already
I think that's her PR team being like
we're breaking this up at least for the
public eye
I want it to be real I mean that's what
he deserves I think so too
what an idiot bro you [__] [__] you
really think that you guys are gonna be
happily ever after it's like the curse
of
mid-men in theater Mid straight men in
theater
they have the craziest God complexes
it's ridiculous because they get
everything they want there are so few of
them really in in troops normally so
they always get the lead so they're
always told that they're incredible they
don't need to get better
um and all of the girls are in love with
them really yes so they think they're
the [__] hottest why are the girls in
love with them just because they're the
only they're like if you're a straight
uh if you're a straight girl and you
like CIS men
that they're they're only like your
options are fairly Limited in the world
of slim pickings
is it like the boy next door does that
mean I was never really a theater boy
goer for her but um would you [__]
SpongeBob
SquarePants yeah the original one we
could talk about it
who wouldn't dude yeah who wouldn't come
on
nicest person do we know how old
SpongeBob's supposed to be I don't want
to talk about it after that question
that's cool with that how old is
SpongeBob of age you think so yes
no he's a homeowner he's dry he's
driving hold on he's a homeowner he's
got a job that's true
he lives by himself yeah that's what I'm
saying he's an adult he has a driver's
license it says in the episode where
pants dude hold on and the episode
sleepy time fans get a glimpse of
SpongeBob's driver's license which lists
his birthday is July 14
1986. yeah yeah oh he's yeah he's not an
adult
given the episode aired in 2000 though
that put him at 14 years old at the time
well we didn't say we wanted to [__] 2
000 SpongeBob what the
[__] one year before that so we're the
same
he's aged like fine wine yeah no you
were born in
1987. you said 2 000 SpongeBob yeah I
was born in 99. I was born in 2000 dead
oh my God
1985 dude your brothers would sponge
um
all right let's watch this forget Ariana
we're going back to Demi
thank God
here it is
no I'm I'm not a fan
um it bugs me because you've been you've
been telling the story wrong and so it
makes me wonder would you not make the
jokes if you knew the correct story dude
that is her
who would even say that you don't know
the story right
I mean there was there was this core
group of girls who were I'm honestly in
my eyes no way evil uh annoyed that all
of the diet stuff was at the front of
the store I literally start to shake a
little bit when I start to remember what
happened that day and I do remember it
sounds like the sister more
I thought that sounded pretty spot-on
the sister I want to hear the mom say a
word that ends with o-r-e or which is
what actually said on the phone phone
and all these texts started coming in
just text after text after text and I
thought what is going on it's Sasha
Sasha this is gonna sound so out there
but just bear with me so I woke up in my
room and there was like three beings
do you want to see your planet she was
just talking about diet culture you know
there have been a lot like her too my
culture oh this is the other the other
sister okay and both these sisters are
angry at me does she have two sisters
only
because her whole that means her whole
inner circles [__] Ethan Klein
I see in three listed on Google
yes it says three an older full sister
named Dallas which is who we saw first a
younger maternal half-sister actress
Madison De La Garza who we see now and
then
Amber but I don't know much about Amber
there's not public Amber's on my team
team Amber eyes you memorize a couple
times where I thought if that's how she
wants to go out then God damn it let her
go out that way but I don't think you
truly ever really give up on someone
like that not her
one more time
dude I'm fully convinced it's one of
these people no I'm I'm not a fan
um it bugs me because you've been you've
been telling the story wrong and so it
makes me wonder would you not make the
jokes if you knew the correct story
right I mean there was there was this
Core group of girls who were I'm
honestly in my eyes pure evil dude that
one is insane hmm
it's either her or Demi
I don't think it's the mom I don't
annoyed that all diet stuff was at the
front
I literally start to shake a little bit
then I start to remember what happened
that day and I do remember you texting
me I was actually looking at I don't
think it's the mom her she's all she's
got a little raspy from age
but the phone kind of Smooths and rounds
out the voice you know what I mean to me
it's between the first sister and Demi
herself okay and Demi herself would be
crazy just text after text after text
and I thought what is going on it's
Sasha Sasha this is gonna sound so out
there but just bear with me so I woke up
in my room and there was like three
beings
do you want to see your planet she was
just talking
there have been a couple times where
it's not her if that's how she dude it
it's her or her sister it has to be it's
damn me for sure
you think it's her Demi yeah dude that
would be so [__] crazy I think it's
hard to believe that she would
be that invested to be calling into
random podcasts but like that tweet
proves that they are invested like why
do they why are they thinking about me
and Trisha I think most sounds like Demi
too that's my vote this is Demi let's do
it
they got to do a poll my opinion's Demi
or her sister Dallas which was the first
one right wants to go out
it bugs me you've been you've been
telling the story wrong and so it makes
me wonder would you not make the jokes
if you knew the correct Story
I mean there was there was this Core
group of this is insane she thinks it's
his mom so the options Demi the mom
Dallas which is the sister that's the
only three I don't think the last one
I don't hear it
so Demi mom Dallas the sister
okay let's see what the community thinks
I am fully convinced it's one of these
people
[Music]
thank you
dude it's Dallas
the people agree that's what I voted for
too
57 Dallas
[Music]
it has to be in Texas
it all makes sense
she's like you don't know the whole
story it's like okay were you there yes
I was there
holy [__] dude
holy [__]
Dallas Lovato called into our Show fact
[Music]
in your opinion
that's a fact in my opinion
that's just a fact
how do we decide is there any way we can
prove this I mean we can reach out to
them
do we have any historical data of the
caller Dan
[Music]
um I mean it does keep logs
how can we figure we can find out the
date I would have to
be tricky to figure out dude Dallas is
at home sweating right now
we're about to pull her number
call her back fine let me see what I can
find it might it might have been too
long ago but
how far so this was in um
like 2021 yeah 2021 yeah
the Casey is good by the way it's better
than I remember
it's good the chicken quesadilla I love
it they killed the quesadillas over
there they kill it
yeah I'm not it was March 7th 2022
Actually March 7th 2022. I I don't
I'm still looking but I'm not saying
oeda look at the archive if you can't
find it is there a chance we could
subpoena the company yeah
yeah I suppose there is I want to search
their Data Center
I need to pull some of their hard drives
for data analysis
well I am going through the twitters on
that day
did you see if there's any passive
aggressive tweets interesting good idea
we have to get to the bottom of this
people watching help us
[Music]
what did she say her name was Sasha
that's gotta be a hint
Sasha sounds like the mom's accent
fascia
so there is a name uh
s-a-i-s-h-a
yeah sounds like that would be
pronounced like that right yeah
so I just wonder if uh any of them have
like
friend follow somebody he's like that's
such a strange name that to come up with
that I feel like you would have to know
somebody named that uh CG cartel said
have Zach Sound by each of them saying a
certain word and play it back to back
that would be good
um Scott has a really good point he says
it's definitely Dallas I don't think the
mom would care enough to call in
the sisters are younger and on social
media enough to tweet yeah I don't think
the you know what I mean that makes
sense to me
do they have any aunts or
like any other extended family that
might be public figures
Sasha
Lovato
say yeshu
guys you gotta help us we need a whole
team spirit on our team effort on this
this is
say that say what what I'm sorry cam you
said March 7 was the day yeah 2022. okay
I guess we should do this too if you're
that person and you're watching
like get in contact with us I don't know
how they'd prove it but yeah yeah let's
start there right
if you're still a fan after all we've
said and thought about it yeah your
sister fat chance
dude don't say fat chats when I'm
talking about damning that's not what I
meant uh it doesn't look like there is a
way to see previous callers like that so
that's a dead end I'm afraid maybe how
do I know this is diet
I don't know we need to give that to you
Lena
it tastes it
it tastes like normal it tastes like it
might be but that's the magical Baja
Blast it tastes like beef jerky they
like
messed up our order significantly
are you did we get enough food because I
I literally am full from this quesadilla
you want food
I think we're good I think we have
enough I have I have a joke I got my
stuff they forgot my [__] but they
forgot the shumpalumpa again
um
they're hard to come by so wait what did
we miss what did they [__] up oh AB gave
me one of his chicken whatever the [__]
um yeah thank you uh but they missed my
Crunch Wrap and I got a shrimpa Loompa
too see
Wows and a Crunchwrap are missing just
lost and lost the time dude Oblivion
dude and maybe what did you what did you
miss out on
uh no my they have mine but I I gave
mine to that because one of mine because
I got extra on purpose because I felt
like they were going to do that I swear
that's what I do okay guys I have a two
tacos and a burrito here if anybody
wants it please
please please please take it I'm not
gonna eat this [__]
okay you're generous
thank you very generous
with the driver forgets about you
foreign
there was a girl over the weekend who
slapped fousey in the face on live
stream
and he started singing that song in
response and
it was the I'm sorry I had to walk away
because it was so [__] funny it
wasn't right but it was just the
situation why was he was she short why
was she I don't know I think he's I
couldn't tell from a stream right here
please by all means enjoy you're welcome
Alexa Nicholas might know her
is that right is there a connection
can we does Alexa Nicholas have tea on
the lovados
I can
somebody just posted that
wow he's going in on Twitter right now
on Justin Long
I'm keeping my eye on give me give me I
want to read it you want to see yeah
I like [__] on Justin long I don't
know why because she has her show is
like daily
I'm sick of that [__] guy trying to
sell me Max all like my whole childhood
it's not happening Justin stopped mate
trying to make it happen
there's like one of her tweet threads
Justin long has a minor problem oh
does she really is spicy mm-hmm
a quote from Ashton Kutcher not me
really
check out my Live tonight
for more context yeah I'm gonna give you
more context so there's also this I'll
send it to you
Jason long
Justin you did that last time too yeah I
don't know what's happening sorry
apologies to
Jason long I mean it sounds like he kind
of sucks so Justin Long hey bro remember
me quick question what is wrong with you
hmm
so I'd be adopting you wouldn't your own
daddy be insulted DM's from just along
to a 15 year old girl
what the [__] is this in 2019 I see your
little blue
dick check mark I see your little blue
dick check mark
I mean say no more about about Justin
long that Ashton Kutcher clip from
punked is like that was crazy GG forever
she also commented on that wow you knew
she was a fan of you on Disney barf
emoji
she also posted at Justin Long
all right what else we got we got um as
we round out the show here
we have a tick tock
plastic surgeon who's dancing while his
uh I think their parent their patients
are you uh not euthanized they'd be uh
not euthanized
they'd be
butchered
under
oh put under um what's it called
anesthesia anesthesiaized
euthanized would mean they're dead right
right
that's to put down
um and so they're dancing as they're as
their clients are euthanized on the
table or do you guys want to talk about
the Whistler blower confirms aliens
these are the two options we have
anybody want to pick what was the
non-alien one again
Tick Tock plastic surgeon lost her
license
for making tick tocks while her patients
were passed let's do that because the
alien thing was kind of bunked so I feel
like that this will be more entertaining
you feel the alien thing has already
been debunked
there's nothing to debunk it's just a
dude who came in and said like yeah we
got aliens
Source trust me bro you guys know how I
feel about this stuff anesthesia is
thank you guys euthanized and
anesthesized pick one or the others the
same
it's the same thing except one person
wakes up one doesn't
let's do a let's do a poll I'm a man of
the people after all
tick tock
doctor
or aliens
Tick Tock is our home
you guys decide
I'm not uh
Chum
where the [__] is my food you owe it to
me
all right tick tock doctor uh let's see
Tick Tock Docker doctors in the lead 57
percent
alien folks get your vote in Now's the
Time 43 aliens no
56 doctor
get your votes in Alien people 45 alien
it's narrowing
this could go either way but it's
looking Doctor
56 I think Tick Tock doctor just went up
which pretty much oh no is going to be a
dub for the doctors and a l for the
aliens
there's no aliens this you know what I
mean stupid
dumb
no [__] aliens there's no bodies
stop it
all right so Tick Tock doctor let's take
a look plastic surgeon known on Tick
Tock as Dr Roxy has been banned from
practicing medicine in Ohio after
authorities determined that she injured
patients while live streaming their
procedures to hundreds of thousands of
viewers wait that sounds like a crime
yeah see I I you know what I mean like
like removing her license I don't think
goes far enough the State Medical Board
of Ohio permanently revoked the medical
license of Catherine Roxanne Grau and
find her 4500 that's it for failing to
meet the standard of care three patients
reported having severe complications
after Grau operated on them
the board found that while Grau was
performing surgeries she live streamed
parts of her patients procedures on Tick
Tock spoken to the camera and answered
viewer questions
from her more than 825 000 followers
dude that's nuts
her Tick Tock seems to be deactivated or
deleted so let's see if we can dig up
some of her videos nope our Instagram
deleted too yeah
I mean that makes sense it's like
okay here it is
oh this lady is crazy
I gotta mute this obviously
so here she is basically dabbing on the
graves of her patients
over multiple clips
bro you went to medical school
proxy [__] cool
oh this is like a man who the [__] are
you dude this is just a stitch because
the account's gone so all that exists we
don't have any the stitches we don't
have it or not no I could I was
surprised I cannot find any of her lives
a bunch of seriously yeah
that's not fun it's less fun
uh growl 44 told the post that she was
obviously devastated
over her patients complications but
maintain that live streaming the surgery
Tick Tock use did not affect the
procedure what about it being like
unethical
accused the Medical Board of bullying
her during her suspension oh poor doctor
growl
worried
oh no crowd built up a considerable
social media following on take that well
she can open like a black
uh
like a black market doctor unit and like
Tijuana
Cheapo deals cheap cheap those jobs on
the cheap cheap with Dr growl
um
she built up considerable following
started live streaming parts of her
patients surgeries to help demystify the
secrecy around surgeries
yeah I don't think it's a secret
you can easily find out what they're
doing you know I mean there's like crazy
infographs
the Ohio Board warned growl about live
streaming surgery in 2018 and 2021 but
she continued doing it
Legend
Arnold said that many patients went to
her because of her Tick Tock presence
three cases she said were cited by the
board were live streamed between
December 2020 and March 2022.
growl performed a liposuction and a
Brazilian butt lift on a patient who
suffered severe abdominal pain and
cramping
a year later another patient was
hospitalized for an infection that
required her breast implants be removed
now I know this stuff happens though
when you're doing a ton of plastic
surgery that's why they have like they
have all kinds of insurances and stuff
um
so
I don't think the problem is that some
surgeries went sideways I think it's
that she was live streaming no
yeah you could probably make an argument
that I wasn't giving her work full
attention here she is pretty important
and like surgery
this is her
physician known as Dr Roxy
there you go she's got blood on her
fingers so this is the footage of like
so if you want to get in the OR and see
behind the scenes and how this stuff
works but now Dr Roxy whose real name is
Catherine growey has been she may have
had stripped of her you know somewhat of
a good intent here but this is
unbelievably I don't think she had a
good intent it seems like she just wants
attention she wants to demystify surgery
dude is that he must defying it
yeah I don't know I prefer it mystified
yeah keep that [__] you know what I mean
I go to sleep I wake up it's done
that's why you go to school for 12 years
and I don't do [__] right
since by the State Medical Board in Ohio
Kelsey Cardenas went to Dr Roxy
for a breast lift she live streamed your
surgery she did do you feel that that
could have contributed to what happened
do you think she wasn't paying attention
re-watching it I saw a couple cuts that
she made when
she was clearly talking to the camera or
focused on what she was saying to them
okay what are you a doctor now
what's your credentials to
I won't criticize the cut right I gotta
say if someone botches a surgery of mine
I would wish it was recorded that's true
I'd assume it's easier to sue if you
have video proof of them watching oh
well that's interesting yeah I mean so
I'm kind of I'm kind of pro really dumb
I'm kind of pro Tick-Tock uh yeah every
doctor's body cams like cops [__] yeah
that's smart
that's awesome we trust nobody
she's the famous position known Dr Roxy
what a dumbass
that is pretty well just imagining the
time and effort it takes to go through
medical school do your residency pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars right
just to lose it all for that [__] for a
Drop of Cloud
I wonder what she's doing now
who wants to lose some money today
I'm I'm cool with the black market Dr
Roxy
you probably couldn't open that in
America but Tijuana
maybe on the border like oh there's a
mountain Market medical industry in here
too I'm sure
Black Market medical yeah because she
live stream it
um
that would probably be inadvisable given
the history but I guess there's nothing
to really stop her no
because if she goes to Tijuana she might
be able to live stream it right
who's gonna stop her the cartel
somebody stop me
oh man is there any more footage of her
I've lived for that uh I'm seeing
when I was going through YouTube it's
mostly just the same set of footage it
seems like yeah the ones we've seen were
the ones that were preserved
hey um
you are wait what does that mean uh Mr
Beast is allegedly suing ghost kitchen
Partners over Mr Beast burger what and
he cites me as an example you're one of
the videos listed
oh there's wait well I want to review
all the ones
so he soon so who's he suing
I'm just finding it right now I'm
looking into it um look at my fat ass
who's that hamburger they closed down
yeah I remember he announced he was
winding it down okay they're now owning
his partner virtual dining Concepts
allegedly okay this I'm really
interested Mr Beast is suing his ghost
kitchen partner over inedible Mr Beast
burgers
he's suing them
these are the people that tried to make
a a ghost kitchen with me
and I said [__] no I'm not doing that
because I saw what a disaster Beast
Burger was I was like I'm not it's just
gonna be [__] I recreated Willy Wonka's
Chocolate we are currently surrounded by
countless sharks
Mr B partner with virtual dining
Concepts to make branded food items
fans have described Mr Beast Burger as
revolting disgusting and so nasty
YouTube personality Mr Beast is suing
the company responsible for the Branded
line of fast food
including the Mr Beast Burger citing
inedible food delivers the deliveries to
customers company virtual dining
Concepts partnered with James Donaldson
aka Mr Beast in 2020 to launch the menu
out of a ghost kitchen storefronts have
no physical presence whose food is made
and served out of other existing
restaurants I mean who would have
guessed that this would be a terrible
idea
what the [__] is this
yeah
I don't think I ever saw this one no we
did we're sure there's a bunch more dude
it's disgusting
who cooked this
no one cooked it yeah yeah right
oh my God that is vile
yeah that's [__] holy [__]
I wonder I wonder about this lawsuit
though because it's like you kind of got
in bed with
incompetent dummy concept
here's a concept anybody could cook this
food anywhere in the country
do they need credentials no
don't need a restaurant no
awesome
's lawsuit alleges that virtual dining
Concepts was more concerned with
expanding the line than quality control
as a result Mr Beast Burger has been
regarded as misleaning poor reflection
on Mr B's brand it provides low quality
products yada yada
that being said he has been promoting
the [__] out of it until like even like
a month ago
[Music]
I've watched all of his videos and it's
always like it's time for dinner bring
out the Mr Beast Burger not sure right
the other people watching the videos
I'll take your word for it
it'd be awesome if one of the
contestants got like food poisoning
I was like yo this shit's Raw
[Laughter]
it's 20 20 dancing is uses all my
favorite hype up a line of fast food
yada yada
virtual dining didn't respond yep Mr
Beast announced that he would be
stepping away from Mr Beast Burger in
June
so not long ago well everyone was like
finally man
so here's the lawsuit I [__] love
that dude I'm in this [__]
let's see
before June it was his last tweet about
it was September
let's take a look so here's the
complaint
when Joe dim are you serious look at how
this starts when Joe DiMaggio was asked
why he hustled on every play of every
game he responded that there's always a
kid who may be seeing me for the first
time I owe him my best this encapsulates
the philosophy that is one of the most
accomplished and prolific online content
creators in the world Jimmy Donaldson
probably really
nature do lawyers are out of control
sometimes for these briefs
Joe DiMaggio
I mean then why did you keep working
with them for years
go to Joe
all right this is pretty great so well
that sucks finally ordered our first Mr
Beast burger and then realized after the
first bite that it was mostly just raw
meat [__]
I just don't understand how you can hold
them accountable when like you're
Outsourcing to just a bunch of random
[__] weirdos we're trying to find the
rest of the world
like dude literally doesn't know how to
cook a burger
let's see
wait I was saying scroll back up what
were some of these quotes I just saw in
all caps how could you do this to me
Jimmy equally disturbing many customers
believe that Mr Beast is personally
responsible for this mess as evidenced
by statements such as how could you do
this to me Jimmy
to me that's giving me kav Kev lawsuit
uh
there was one review that said Ryan
Kavanaugh is a fat [__]
on trailer
Ethan Klein is responsible for that
okay he'll look more more uh
this is really an interesting lawsuit
I'm not sure about how I feel it's going
to go
to be fair I'm not familiar with any
details though
where's the um it's in the second part
so it has to if you go back out oh yeah
okay
this is right is this just supplemental
yeah supplemental exhibit B these are
the exhibits yeah it's number five page
five let's see
YouTube reviews
oh no no no no
not our boy Eddie taking the number one
spot
the deceptive world of ghost kitchens
you know I remember his review of Beast
Burger being not that bad I remember he
was like pleasantly surprised that it
wasn't like a nightmare hmm
Mr Beast number one on YouTube trending
the Eddie's video I think that's why you
put it first
we're number three let's [__] go
right now dude
[Applause]
because y'all could have captured could
you guys please grab a better image
why why have you done this
let's take a look at the review it's a
powerful frame thanks lawyers wait the
URL doesn't work what kind of dumb [__]
is this
it's a high life could probably find it
quick it should work three they didn't
link to it did these ones work
hmm
trying the worst restaurants in La
there's the clip go look for the clip Mr
Beast Burger is gross
Mr Beast Burger is a disaster
underwhelming Mr Beast I mean I hate to
say it but y'all should have canceled
this partnership years ago if it was
obviously not working out
Mr Beast Burger raw Patty dude I cannot
believe the amount of raw food people
are getting
Raw
oh
well
they got 85 pages of this [__] Jesus
oh and we're now see now they're going
meticulously argued document now they're
going a little bit down
sad that Mr Beast would put his name on
this this is a one star review guys so
disappointing fries were supposedly
seasoned but tasted like soggy Bland
fries straight from the freezer section
Nashville hot spicy chicken sandwiches
with nothing like the picture no spice
it was poorly put together dude what the
[__] why are you including that yeah
like
desperate weird [__] yeah that's weird
like uncooked meat is like dangerous
like that that if if you have reports of
people saying like hey I got a burger
and it was like basically Raw that to me
seems like compelling off right but but
like uh it was not enough salt it's like
that's not that's not actionable I'm
suing them not enough salt damn it
pepper that picture though what the [__]
is this looks like cardboard
someone delivered that
worst Burger I've ever had Betty was
completely flat and looked like rubber
tasted like rubber I had to throw it in
the bin
holy [__]
that's crazy I don't think I've ever
seen a burger that bad no never I feel
like these ghost kitchen craters are
just taking a piss at everyone just
buying their [__] just I think the ghost
kitchen thing is like a dead meme at
this point yeah
the only I sometimes see them when I'm
ordering from like Postmates
or whatever and you can always tell
which one's the ghost kitchen because it
doesn't have real photos it's just like
stock photos yeah yeah and there's a
bunch of them here I feel like look at
this [__] dude you could die from that
look at this raw chicken my
seven-year-old ate into this Rob Beast
chicken sandwich oh
you know you know what the bacteria
infection you can get from that yeah oh
this is why you don't Outsource
something as important as food I mean
food is important right we [__] put
it in our bodies we got to make sure
that we know what's going on you ever
watch Bar Rescue
like with John John Taffer dude John
Taffer in here to [__] some [__] up in
those [__] ghost kids for sure
there's a lot of raw chicken there's
just three of them dude that's
afterwards ew four look at that [__]
dude disgusting
ah it's so vile no
tip Talk reviews the way he was holding
that burger just [__] gripping into
it I think which one oh no that's such a
sad realization that's tragic it's like
I'm gonna die chicken tastes a little
rubbery huh yeah and you know the
chicken that comes from Beast Burger
ain't in tip top quality
okay cool well
good luck I guess
maybe before no shot
okay I just got a breaking news Demi
Lovato's mom follows the quartering yes
she does I just checked
so
I don't know what that means what what
does that mean I don't know
at least aware of this fear you know why
do you care
it you have to admit that's a little
strange right Jeremy interesting
oh I have never tried this Dorito one I
am her biggest fan let me try this
Dorito [__]
not long for this planet
but you just have all
all these sound bites of Germany just
talking about dying I'm sweaty I'm fat
I'm overweight
no I would genuinely like not watching
the quartering [__] myself this is
probably conservative
you know even then
even then yeah I mean I guess that's
true like imagine watching this video as
an adult like just to open any of his
videos
the quartering it's just such a disaster
I'd be down on my knees first of all the
thumbnail
wait right he he had videos criticizing
Demi
does Demi's mom hate
her daughter
I don't think so give them her
documentary
Vado is uh uh Demi Lovato is trash
someone needs to tell Demi's mom so that
she can call in so maybe
if she hates
or no damn his mom is on our side if she
hates Demi look no matter how you feel
Demi's mom you gotta stop following
quarter cover yeah it's making you look
bad either way imagine a full-grown
woman clicking this thumbnail right and
then watching this video stream your
break not this look at this [__]
protected by fair use
what is this dude
the framing the face the man the way he
talks
streamers Hassan and xqc destroyed for
lazy [__] quartering talking about
lazy content
my name is Jeremy my channel is called
my name is Jeremy who wants to do Club
machines let's see has he done a Dylan
Mulvaney video today
I've been uh well there's a trans video
from three hours ago movini blasted
again second row and is that from today
no shot still oh that was seven years
ago yeah I've been periodically checking
in I actually stopped the count because
it got so high three days at last count
he was up to like 60 plus how can you
shut the [__] up and that was over a
month ago Dude and he's still doing it
pretty much daily
yeah and the views are decent I mean
look I mean he knows his audience right
Dylan Mulvaney roasted after insane
speaking fee revealed okay God forbid
you make money
I have nearly 50 videos on the wall
trans people aren't allowed to make
money hell no breaking news
I mean it's pretty funny just to [__]
scroll through these Demi Lovato's mom
watches this apparently
trans rugby player puts three women on
stretcher in single game
calls the cops to defend it
I'm sure that's exactly what happened
yep
Bud Light just purged everyone yo she's
still doing Brie Larson videos oh of
course
how what she's not even doing anything I
think there's yeah there's a new Marvel
movie with her coming out lucky but this
one got him half a million views that's
nuts that's like his most viewed video
when he talks about Brie Larson mm-hmm
what
why do they care about Brie Larson I
wonder if he's still got the shed
look at Tom Hanks what did he do to his
face wait that's not Tom Hanks
here's Dylan Mulvaney six days ago Bud
Light ruthlessly mocked for new ad
Bud light's sinking
here's another Dylan Mulvaney film of
any begging for work from woke
colleagues
and then when she gets work it's like
look how much she got paid
here's another one that's this is what
this is General I wasn't exaggerating
it's pretty much daily daily upload Bud
Light under investigation after Ron
DeSantis blasts them
damn
I mean what here's another one
new app to text woke this is like a
visual realized this is like a visual
representation of paranoid paranoid
personality disorder like this is a
personality disorder in
distilled into visual uh thumbnails
still fire though
dude best thumbs in the game we gotta
get an offense game
without his thumbnail artist he'd be
nothing I agree I emulated that one time
yeah you did yeah it looked good
hmm
[__] me man
there's recording shout out Demi
Lovato's mom
shout out
oh did he look at her food Lena
yeah she did she did okay cool
all right well that's about it that's it
this food is so soggy that I
can't really rate it
[Music]
I can't rate it
let's see other taco supreme
take a look here
[Music]
not that good soggy as [__] and edible
damn
look at my arms jiggle
still got some work to do
[Laughter]
there it is where it is people
all right
um is there a uh members stream tomorrow
or do I recall that you had okay so
something going on tomorrow
I have a doctor tomorrow I'm doing the
blood test to see if what's the deal
uh-huh and then I have a call
let me let me see if I if we can work it
in
so tomorrow I got the blood test I'm
getting my hair cut tomorrow
I just have a call with my psychiatrist
we got a lot going on
my friend would you guys be upset if I
didn't do a show tomorrow
to be fair I was supposed to get a I was
supposed to miss last week's but still
did it
right that is true
um so probably not I'm sorry guys it's
just a pretty busy day
Fouseytube people are saying check
fousey what's going on
hi we're visible the Wireless company
that makes things
Boosie tube Shredder you cannot have
Taco Bell man
no chance that's the last thing you need
brother we are here for vibes
Freddie I'm so sorry we'll have to eat
when we get home
God the commercials on Twitch are nuts
piece of [__]
I wish we had commercials like this it
was like a two minute unskippable and
it's burned in you can't even like get
rid of it with Adblock all right what's
this
okay this is interesting all right buddy
he gave this guy his phone
never give up the mic that's 101
broadcasting
got it all right sounds good bro
appreciate you wait where's
looks different today
you guys think you want to do some more
canvas slash marijuana someone just hand
babies on the podcast he can't right now
I don't know what that means
AB has the answer
I don't know maybe oh I think they want
me to call him call him
let's see what's going on
and check in on our boy I love this game
what's fousey doing
oh he passed 30k
this is very mysterious content right
now I think this is the guy so over the
weekend he set up like a GoFundMe for
someone in Chicago
's on the phone with foosi right now
uh
even uh Ethan suggested I'd call you
check on you because the chat was
telling me I should or live right she's
talking to his mind I don't have you on
it I don't have you on speaker or
anything
you gotta we gotta get the mic going
we're here AV
this is Mike open dad
uh he he's having a private conversation
with him first before
he says people are worried about you do
you want to say anything I heard Abe do
an an audible uh
exhale of disappointment or something
he says I'll call you after the show
where is he
what's happened what do you say Abby uh
he said that he just
not to worry about him he's all right he
just needed a breather
it's just been a lot of strain on him so
what is this what am I watching right
now so he has a gentleman named Nadeem
holding the camera right now who's a
friend of his
actually he said uh he's gonna send me
the deem's number
so he could let chat know that he's all
right he just needs a breather
so he just mysteriously disappeared and
gave these guys his phone there's a new
PIN message baby
Foose just left Vivid we gotta find him
that's the pin comment from one of his
mods he says they don't know where the
[__] he is
oh he's fine we talked to him he's good
yeah he's good
we found him guys
mystery solved but yeah don't don't burn
out on this [__] bro
you know what I mean
you don't have to stay on 24 7. yeah
just when you're doing something cool I
agree that is a lot which you do a lot
right you do a lot of cool stuff
you found ways to make it uh fun and
interesting
he did his month you know I mean he did
31 days I think that's
more than enough
well also it's not going to be worth it
if he's like yeah if you're losing it
then what's it all for
right
all right foosi
let me see what these guys are talking
about before we go he's here for a
purpose right exactly this is his
purpose uh to use his voice okay
there it is guys
people are flat wait
somebody said that lovados are live on
Tick Tock I checked um
yes uh Madison and their mom are live
like making brownies and the comments
are saying like H3 Sasha can we open it
I did open it they aren't talking about
they're not reading chat it looks like
they're not I want to hear them talk
though okay it's Dallas no it's Madison
and the mom oh [__] they are playing
music though okay so that's not good
all right guys listen up
we had a great Monday episode we've
we've done so much together we've had
the joys of announcing uh
we're having another baby
that's right
the tragedy uh that is um
I would I didn't want to say I mean but
it's actually it's very sad that uh
Angus Angus Cloud Angus cloud
talented young man yeah
and we've also had discoveries we've had
uh Thrills the lovados have been outed
as our mysterious color
Sasha
whoever you are but yeah guys sorry I
won't be live for members tomorrow I
need to go do a blood test and see
what's the [__] deal do I have Lupus
do I have leukemia I don't like the joke
but like I don't think I do
because my annotatitors hi I've got that
Anna tighter
so I want to say this
I'm not doing never stream tomorrow
cause I might be dying or have
autoimmune disease I need to go see my
hematologist
to do some blood analysis to make sure
my values haven't gone up it's the
hematologist
making sure I'm not dying so I can do
more shows for you seeing the
hematologist
and then I've got to get
uh Imaging of my internal organs to make
sure I don't have two mirrors inside of
me
a lot of people say
hey forget about it it's nothing
but then I took a blood test and the
Anna tighter was way out of control it
was way too high
my white blood cells are elevated my
bloodlets are also up
it might be lupus it might be
[Music]
nothing no
oh you ended
[Music]